apron
blue apron sends gourmet recipes and all
the fresh ingredients you need to make
them right to your door
our listeners get their first two meals
for free just go to blueapron.com joey
and start cooking incredible meals at
home with blue apron that's
blueapron.com
joey show is also brought to you by me
undies.com go to meundies.com right now
slash go to meundies.com joey right now
and get 20 off of your first order plus
shipping is always free for orders in
the us and canada and the show is
brought to you by onyt.com go to
onit.com and use codeword church to get
10 off of all the great optimization
products
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
monday
february 1st you know what happens on
the first
everybody's down to zero [ __ ] we're
all the [ __ ] same on the first paying
the rent yeah it really is yeah we're
all [ __ ] the same on the first tom
rhodes in studio my main man as usual
the flying jew
what happened this weekend i had a great
weekend you went to see pugs yeah you
weren't done you didn't buy one no no
what the [ __ ] i wish but i took a page
out of your book ever since i've been
dating my girlfriend and you try to buy
expensive gifts you try to like jewelry
like they tell you that's what [ __ ] you
need to go to sales you get [ __ ] in
the ass they put you on a credit card 21
points
for a [ __ ] ring that's hollow they
[ __ ] they [ __ ] you and it's never
i've
i like you giving gifts and i've never
quite gotten the reaction from her that
i've wanted she's always liked it but
it's never like
excited or speechless and this i told i
gave i told her that i was like the gift
you're gonna like the most is the one
that i spent the least on i called the
pug rescue i said do you mind is it cool
my girlfriend loves pugs can we come
down and play and they said of course
so we went down there and spent like two
hours just playing with dogs and she had
that's all she's been talking about she
had a great time sometimes it's as
simple as [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
right or wrong that's beautiful it
really is beautiful look at the leaf and
we went to like a fancy dinner the night
before cost like a hunt like a hundred
but it was a nice dinner and then it's
the playing with with shelter dogs that
it
made her a year like she's saying we
have to do it all the time now it's but
you you both have good marriages so it's
you know what it takes and it's it's
it's i'm learning now because this is my
first
real real well it's nice to be with a
woman who is happy with simple things it
really is isn't that crazy mike my wife
she didn't want an expensive wedding
ring like i wanted to you know the the
ego in the man you know i want to like
you know i i never thought i'd get
married so whatever but i thought always
you got to get a spectacular ring she
insisted on like a really
simple ring she does she hates spending
money she doesn't like to shop how long
have you been married now uh five years
in april jesus christ yeah
that came out of nowhere either like you
went and then i was the last person in
the world i thought we'd get married
really yeah i and my parents are
divorced
uh i thought it was outdated institution
and didn't want anything to do with it
never saw an example of a good marriage
um you know uh but my wife is amazing
she's she's a great woman she's from
holland and uh she's a photographer
we uh a lot of [ __ ] happened in my life
uh i i've had a massive transformation
you know my father was killed by a drunk
driver in 2009 that really [ __ ] me up
because my dad
uh he was like life of the party guy
always had a cocktail in the hand uh
vietnam veteran he flew helicopters in
vietnam he was shot down he was a tough
bad [ __ ] everyone died in the
helicopter except for him and his
co-pilot
who he dragged across a field under
heavy fire and then they had to wait in
the bushes for like three hours after he
died i i found the letter from the army
saying white he got like five medals for
this oh he never told you no no he did
but he didn't like elaborate on the
story i knew that he had been shot down
you know like bad ass veterans only talk
about stuff but i was close with my dad
he told me you know how he had saved a
guy and unhooked him uh and dragged him
across the field and [ __ ] but i didn't
realize that you know how it's a
hollywood movie basically anyway my dad
loved comedy uh he had comedy albums
prior was his favorite that's why you
know my dad drove me to my first open
mic night all this [ __ ]
so uh i was like really [ __ ] up uh
when he died and angry at the the drunk
driver who killed him um
and so my wife really like nursed me
through this [ __ ]
and then uh i i realized i'm never gonna
find a woman as amazing as her and uh we
we planned to get married and then my
sister had stage four breast cancer for
four and a half years and then a few
days before we were going to get married
they said she's got 24 hours to live
and we got married at my sister's
hospital bedside the day before she died
of cancer
and like i was really close with my
sister you know just the fact that my
wife would do that
and because like i don't know a lot of
women would be like i ain't giving up my
big day
i didn't get married in a hospital right
you know but like i got married in a
[ __ ] hospital next to my sister
before she died of cancer and she
clapped and said congratulations to her
breathing mask
it was the last word she ever spoke and
like uh and so like then that like
really uh
[ __ ] me up i was like really angry
after that so uh then i was angry at god
because like i always you know
believed in god and my family's really
religious and [ __ ] so i went through
this massive um
you know uh it was it was a really
difficult couple years and then my wife
really nursed me we're traveling around
the world she helped me uh you know heal
and laugh again and [ __ ] so i mean my
wife is is incredible when you said you
were mad at god what did you feel like
like
well i tell you man i went to uh because
my family are all jesus freaks and i
never you know like i think you should
be a good person and don't be a [ __ ] and
that was jesus's message don't be a [ __ ]
so
uh i was never like a
real you know
church person reading the bible all that
and i've been open to you know i was
obsessed with buddhism when i was
younger and um i'm fascinated by
religions and things like that but uh
i was a and i've always been that you
know me you know me for years i've
always been a really happy guy
after my sister died i had so much anger
and it was really con uh
we went to ireland i had gigs after my
wedding and
there was this
uh there's a late night hamburger place
in ireland called super max
and they're all over ireland and you
don't want to be in a super max after
midnight because it's drunks looking for
fights
and i was in galway my favorite place in
ireland if you ever go to ireland dublin
is great but galway is just the [ __ ]
it's this mini san francisco university
seaport if you were a musician or gay in
ireland you would go to galway so
uh there's a cool rock club there where
everybody played the pogues and u2 and
sinead o'connor and that's that's how
they do the comedy the guy that owns
it's one of my oldest friends in comedy
so
we're there
and
uh
like one o'clock in the morning we
wanted to get some some food and his
brother was with him so it's my wife
kevin his brother we're in super max
there's these rugby drunk thugs in there
[ __ ] with uh kevin and his brother
they're looking for a fight and then we
got out of there but his brother was
still in there and these four guys all
jump on him and start pounding him and
then kevin runs in to help his brother
i'm not a fighter but i'm not you know
and then you can't let somebody come i'm
gonna you know i'm gonna help my friend
you know if something happens i'm always
there for my friends right and then also
it's my honeymoon man you don't look
like a coward on your honeymoon that
could [ __ ] be a black mark on your
wedding when you're on your marriage
forever
i look at her and i look at my wife and
i go i'm going i'm going in baby it's
kevin and and she and she she's like
yeah and so i go in and i haven't
punched anybody in i don't know 20 years
and
uh
this guy he was the [ __ ] stirrer who had
started it i run in i punched the guy in
the cheek and apparently like that's the
last place in the world you want to hit
somebody because this is bone i broke my
finger and i had to go to the hospital
the next day but i mean
you know the fight was pretty much done
when i went in there
you know i was like dean martin in an
old west movie
saloon fight you know
i looked i looked good nobody hit me
somebody goes by yeah
so i'm totally dean martin in there but
um
we went after we we did galway we go to
dublin and i was talking to an irish
comedian
friend of mine and uh i told him the
story about my sister dying and getting
into the fight and he said you know what
i think tom
i think you wanted to punch god in the
face
and god wasn't available and that's why
you punched that guy
so um yeah i wanted to punch yeah it
makes sense yeah did you get i wanted to
punch god in the face so
if you're that guy that i hit
you're sorry
i'm sorry i was i was upset i hope you
punched the holy spirit out
it's really weird cause
i always describe that i describe uh
being mad at god you know what i'm
saying like just
a couple times in my life when your
central nervous breakdown yeah when
you're down when you're down
you can't explain why god would do
something like this can't you see i'm
wounded down here you [ __ ] and then
you're gonna throw something else on top
of me so you're the first person in a
long time that i've heard say that
that's why i thought it was interesting
yeah
no that you know when you got married i
had heard it through like the grapevine
and i was in shock and i didn't know
anything about the hospital now yeah
[ __ ]
but you're one of those dudes you know
you're a real comedian when i got into
comedy
it was to do what you do
but then i had the felonies i can't
travel abroad so i killed that whole
[ __ ] dream
so how to make what i got you know what
i'm saying i go like catalina island and
make the league
but you've led that life you know
somebody gave me a book for you it's one
of those books that you open up and it's
a safe
remember when we were kids you would
open up those books oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah and for me he gave me i forget the
name body and soul or something but for
me he gave me uh lenny bruce uh the one
i always talk about how to talk dirty
and influence people oh the other one
the one that he lives in the chelsea and
he's
doing heroin with the jazz musicians and
uh
and when i read that that was the
[ __ ] book what the hell you put chalk
on the table
and i got it all over me [ __ ]
when you had it over here that's what
happened is that that table marijuana
chocolate yeah yeah so
reading that that's what really like i
was getting it this was way before i got
separated
this is when i was about 27 20 i just
got out of prison i read that book when
i was locked up and i was like this is
an interesting life this is no
responsibility life
like if you want it you could just live
under the [ __ ] radar
so when i got into comedy it was to live
under the radar to just travel and
whatever came no one to answer to nobody
no one to look out for you nothing when
you're out there driving in some [ __ ]
town in uh
you know missoula montana you don't know
what's going on
it's trying to outrun a hurricane a
tornado
there's a point where you're sitting
there a little confused
but then you're like what am i confused
about
there's no confusion here i got no boss
i'm gonna do 60 miles an hour i'm gonna
drive till the tank goes empty fill it
up get something to eat and then finish
driving and get to mike giggin on those
triple runs when you first start
they could be a little [ __ ]
irritating those triple runs you know i
never did those really i mean i did i
went uh
to
i stayed in montana rich hall's he owns
a ranch right right he's like an old
friend of mine my wife and i spent a
month at his ranch like five years ago
and then for fun i did those um i did
like a few of those gigs because they
were notoriously the worst gigs in
america in america but tremendously
tremendous for a comedian and they build
a lot of character
and they teach you how to live off 50
dollars a day when you want to do coke
and drink
montana coke wow let me tell you
something i got some [ __ ] coke in
montana one time
that was so good i got good coke all
idaho
i went from houston
to somewhere oregon or
it was either oregon or idaho and i got
some [ __ ] blow
from a door chick
that was so [ __ ] hot guys
this guy was thinking or he was way
ahead of the game this had to be 2 000.
this guy was already ahead of the game
he had a hot chick at the door
taking ids
this [ __ ] was so [ __ ] hot big
country woman big natural titties
wranglers on you know boots
[ __ ] banging and after i did comedy
she came over to me
and she's like you do blow and she's
like uh
the mexicans in the back have some
tremendous [ __ ] just
i'm like wait till i get and i was
headlining so they gave me like 100
bucks
i was like [ __ ] yeah what what can i get
for 60 and they gave me a half a eighth
so she goes uh
he you know she gives me the half eighth
and she goes where are you staying at
the whatever hotel and i go yeah
and i went back with the comic we did a
couple lines
and then i said [ __ ] let me go back to
my room about an hour later the angel
knocked on my door
but she was a banger
this was real this is you know this is
life on the road you meet a chick that's
[ __ ] gorgeous
you think that you know this chick uh
probably works at a dog shelter monday
through friday that's what she looked
like
and she came over and she's like yo can
i get high with you i brought beers or
something i go sure i was awake anyway
you know i made it like i had to touch
the coke and all of a sudden she took
her works out
in this little [ __ ] town in montana
she took works out and took some of the
coke and melted it and shot herself no
[ __ ] i had to go outside is that what
work is that work is just yeah it works
it's neat it's working
you don't know the way you showed up
with a little [ __ ] pack no i don't
know
you watch black exploitation films in
the 70s
i never knew it was called words holy
[ __ ] i had to go outside i had to go
outside because i thought i was going to
faint i had to take the coke with me
because i didn't trust a [ __ ] either
now that opened up a complete different
uh you know is that popular
cook
you know i
listen i've seen maybe two people do it
in my life i was never really around
needles you know yeah i never wanted
anything people
who do needles attract other people do
needles
you know it's like you when i first
moved to hollywood the chicks next to us
were heroin chicks two hot lesbian
chicks that just ate each other and did
heroin and both of them had body odor to
kill a [ __ ] moose
and then i talked to her once by the
pool i go what's that smell and she goes
you're probably talking about us i just
made believe like what's that smell
and they told me they wouldn't use soap
with showers
why because the soap would clean their
pores and they don't want their pores to
be clean
you want your pores to be congested so
the heroin doesn't sweat out yeah so it
sits in your [ __ ] body that's great
every time you're dedication and every
time you eat chocolate or something it
kicks it back open so heroin people
don't like sweating they like to fill
their pores up and [ __ ] with [ __ ]
concrete or whatever the [ __ ] were they
the ones that sold me
who how did they make a living these two
broads one of them was like a trust this
was the craziest building me josh wolfe
the girl next to us was beautiful
beautiful had a kid every dad see it
with a resume going on an acting
audition one night i put showtime on
there she was sucking the dick on
showtime my neighbor the girl next to
her the two lesbians didn't bathe
then the girl next to her held the weed
for the guy who lived on the
fourth floor or the second floor white
lightning he was a jewish guy that hung
out with
jewish girl he was a jewish guy that
hung out with black women and did a
jamaican night at some bar on [ __ ] i
swear to god you can't write this [ __ ]
so he would get 10 pounds sent in from
jamaica so he was a [ __ ] so he would
hide in the garage and he would give
this chick half of it she would steal
half of it and sell it to us we'd give
her coke
she'd suck your dick and then we'd steal
like an eighth from her weed she had no
chin
it was unbelievable this chick had no
[ __ ] chin it's amazing how you find
buildings like
this isn't you asked me if i knew what a
rig was no i have no idea the second
floor also like this a mexican kid who
sold coke and he didn't get home till
two so once he came home the party
started the girl on the first floor was
a promoter at one of the bars so she'd
bring freaks on and there was a pool in
the backyard i never got laid back i can
tell you a thousand stories there were
young girls i was 32
i lived upstairs with josh wolf but
that's how crazy that [ __ ] building
was the chick with the chin sucked my
dick a few times without the chin i
forget what her name was she was from
connecticut she had no chin she was like
but she had gigantic titties and that's
all that matters i guess at that time
you know i'm saying when you're doing
powder and craziness
it just
that's crazy it just magnetizes people
like coke just brings people like i've
never had anything people tell them to
attract heroin people
you know how many times you bump into
something that says you want to line a
heroin never
because they just they know only hedberg
really everybody has yeah and i never i
never got i never got into hard drugs uh
it's i stopped doing hard drugs a couple
years ago i stopped drinking alcohol
did you two years ago you see the scar
on my forehead yeah it's getting smaller
what what was that scott from um
i blacked out in philadelphia
helium
i was performing the helium oh jesus
christ and um i was there new year's eve
two years ago
and
three sold out shows uh new year's eve
and then the way the weekend was
uh
i had january 1st the thursday off and
they wanted me to stay for the friday
saturday so um
never am i in a city with a night off
and my wife was in holland visiting her
mother so like if she was with me i
think i would have fallen into her
so um you want the long version of the
shorts very short version so uh
i
had
just move up a little bit don't
use the thing up keep talking
i had 10 pints of sierra nevada very
normal evening i was in some little
working man's bar on sansome street
and uh i just blacked out and fell like
a tree off this bar stool
just booze yeah uh and then i i my head
hit the tile floor and some guys
once my head hit the floor i was wide
awake
and then i feel this dude grabbing me by
the arm and he screams out to the bar we
gotta call an ambulance oh [ __ ] and i
turn to him and i go i go [ __ ] that i
don't have health insurance
don't you dare call an ambulance and he
he looks at me and he goes you got to
get to a hospital
i said how far is the nearest hospital
and he goes two blocks i go two blocks
and you were going to call an ambulance
it's like fifteen thousand dollars
kidding me yeah yeah so don't you sign i
mean that's life in america you know so
i grabbed a wad of napkins and i walked
like john wayne to the emergency room
sat there and uh
i then you know the next day i i had
these frankenstein stitches on my
forehead and a black eye and the last
couple years i was you know i've always
been a heavy drinker always been a big
partier you know it's part of my
identity um i just felt sluggish like i
like an athlete you know you lose step
after uh you know you get a little older
and uh i was starting to get that fat
boozy
alcoholic face that my dad had and like
the booze nose and [ __ ] and i look in
the mirror the next day and i got these
frankenstein stitches and a black eye
and i was like i want to go
one year
seeing what it's like not being drunk
every night of my life because you know
in comedy we get paid in you know one of
the the only perk is free drinks so like
you know i always drank like a fish
everywhere it was part of the
you know the the benefits and
so uh
i
went one year and i got so much [ __ ]
done and i didn't have this
low magnitude depression
all the time
uh and then being hungover all the next
day and feeling like [ __ ] and all these
things i wanted to do was like um
you know you feel bad about yourself
because you know you're not
achieving everything you want to be
doing um
so i felt so great after a year and got
so much [ __ ] done i was like [ __ ] i'm
gonna stick with this
and um it's been two years and
uh now i just gave up the cigarettes how
do you feel after two years what are you
incredible what is your night life now
do you just go to the hotel drink coffee
you know now you know the [ __ ]
cigarettes so that that goes
you know why drink the coffee if you
ain't got the [ __ ] sick i love carl
and i love cigarettes i still love
cigarettes and i still love booze i love
drinking i just like you know i uh i
you know i i i love wine i know a lot
about wine i envision myself maybe in my
60s
maybe having a glass of wine but i think
a nice
10-year stretch at least
seeing how much [ __ ] i can get done i
mean i love comedy i love making jokes
and uh you know i've been working on a
book for a few years there's like a lot
of [ __ ] i want to be doing now you know
look at all these comedians banging out
new hour specials every year you know
it's been a couple years since my last
special i'm really working my ass off to
get my next hour you know i'm i'm
motivated and i'm happy like i said the
main thing is i don't have that low
magnitude depression all the time
which just
happens when you're [ __ ] boozing all
the time what do you mean by that low
magnitude depression do you drink all
the time i don't know
uh there's just certain underlying funk
that you feel
all the time and you think ah well i'm
hungover and it'll wear off
whatever but then like he's the evening
comes and i never drank before shows it
was always after you know i loved comedy
too i mean like sure some second show
fridays uh i i was hammered but uh for
the most part my rule of thumb was never
you know drink before you go on stage um
uh
anyway it it there's just a
uh
did you feel this way like when you were
starting comedy and drinking
no now i feel like when i was young i
feel like comedy's the drug
getting on stage for me is the drug and
thinking up jokes again it's great
because at one point
you know it's like uh you know my dad
was the life of the party i'm the life
of the party i always
intertwined comedy with being the life
of the party you know you're the party
leader and like prior also uh one of my
favorites just the the mythology of
of uh people who party all my heroes
died fat naked and bloated on the
bathroom tile you know what i'm saying
uh jim morrison lenny bruce
you know
so i you know i i wanted to be that uh
you know wild man but you know you get a
little older and you realize
people you love start dropping dead and
you realize you know man there's a
there's a a
[ __ ] hourglass to life
you only get so much
you know when you're young and having
fun it just seems like this endless
thread that's never going to end sara
tiana was here a couple nights ago
and she said that she feels sometimes
that it ages you the road
i mean i was 50 when i was born you know
i'm saying i looked 80 when i was born
uh
it was fun man i always had a great time
and you know i was i was born on the
road as a comedian so i never had the
hang-ups about the road and i always
it's a it's it's a necessary component
to the whole program i always felt but
then again you know i went and did way
too much and
playing all over the i haven't lived
anywhere in 10 years i had everything in
storage so i would spend six months of
the year outside of the united states
last month last year i did five months
in europe
month in asia and then six months all
over the states you know the year before
that i did a month in australia a month
in new zealand and just you know
relentlessly you know but no you're the
last the real deal but i'm talking about
even
from the beginning i mean when you first
walk into your first open mic
you're nervous you get up boom then you
go to your second your third then by the
fourth
people like hey let's have a drink and
all of a sudden you become a social
comic you you you know run with other
comics then you find your clique
and they're all a bunch of drinkers and
drugs they have to get high
and now all you just go out together
four nights a week to do comedy which
always means cocktails there's not one
night you're going to go out when you're
in the beginning and not drink drinking
all night and hanging out with community
hanging out with my favorite thing on
the planet and some people have to go to
work but they don't give a [ __ ] they
stay out till three and do it again the
next night and are you getting like
hammered hammer drunk it's not like one
or two some nights you get really ripped
and some nights you
get the party started but you eat
something you go eat with a bunch of
comedians and you simmer down a little
bit you know some nights you go [ __ ]
for two days i dedicated my life to that
yeah some nights you go for two days and
you don't know
you don't know till you get out there
you don't know what's gonna happen you
might go to a bar
you know most bars will tell you on the
thing well you get two free drinks as a
feature act
and you get there and they check the
chicks from connecticut
and now you got something to talk about
next thing you know she's giving you
free [ __ ] drinks you know i started
out in
orlando and then uh i started
i started out on the southern circuits
after i you know got him a florida then
when i went on the road
i played every town that ends in viller
borough in the southern united states i
played [ __ ] everywhere the
the
late 80s the comedy zone right out of
charlotte they had a comedy zone in
every holiday in highlands creative all
over the southern united states creative
events so like i started out doing those
gigs
every holiday inn oh my god from
prestonburg
ever
west virginia
to [ __ ] uh oh like clarkville
tennessee
i mean i mean you know like
like in a texas like florence uh south
carolina you know uh
jackson mississippi they're jacksonville
they had their own jacksonville they had
all those clubs and then tribble on the
other hand has red lions
so all the red lion ends on the
northwest tribble books pretty much some
of them are mormon you can't curse on
stage but some of them they don't give a
[ __ ] some of them the mormons don't even
give a [ __ ] they're out trying to get a
piece of [ __ ] too it's wednesday night
happy hour works for them too so i
started out you know doing the and then
there was gigs in the midwest and then
you know i just was into this adventure
and i was i started when i was 17. so i
went on the road when i was 18 after i
graduated high school
and uh i had a good enough car my dad
helped me get from this woman that he
was [ __ ]
and
uh i i i i i i went everywhere and i
would be gone for months and and then uh
you know go up to chicago and do guest
sets and hit you know i wanted to be a
comedian and then i would you know i
would work blocks
you know kansas city wherever and uh
milwaukee and all over you know
lexington
and uh
and then i would systematically try and
go do showcase sets at other places so
like you know
for me the road was homer's odyssey you
know i went on the road and uh i i would
go away for
months at a time my my family never knew
when i would be back i'm really jealous
of that lifestyle like it seems like it
would be and i can see that it probably
is is wearing and you miss
we miss certain things but it seems like
it would be so you don't miss
a [ __ ] thing
like you'd be in detroit right like i'd
be in detroit working at joey's comedy
club okay and i have two shows and i'd
be the feature act so the show starts at
7 30. guy does 15 7 40. i'm off at 8 15.
i would schedule a showcase at all joe
society in downtown detroit at 8 45 and
i go right from the stage into the car
shoot down there run in do a showcase
go back through the 10 30 show i was at
gavon you have to hustle man you got to
hustle that's the only way you got to
call the clubs and go hey uh lisa yeah
joey diaz listen i'd like to do a guest
set who recommended you tom rhodes can i
ask you a question mr yeah listen i just
want to know the person who books
is going to be there to make a decision
because once i [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah destroy that [ __ ] room i
don't want to leave there without a
booking and they would just sit on the
other end of the line
that's part of it i would say i got no
choice i got no choice i'm a salesman
and they would giggle sometimes
sometimes they go okay come down at 8 30
wise ass and then hang up on me
especially back then to play the game
you had to cover the land and you had to
you had to go showcase at these places
and get past so you you also you had
little room for air you had to
constantly kill
you know constantly and right on the
show
you know you know it's like somebody uh
we went somewhere about two years ago me
brian and somebody else and we did a
show
and and we went to the town lady's like
okay what do you want to do and we're
like we're going to a hotel room
we got to go freshen up before the show
she's like i thought we were going to
save money i was going to give it back
to the comics we could just hang out in
the restaurant until 8 30.
i'm like are you crazy we did that
we go to a town get there at two in the
afternoon
you know you got three dollars in your
pocket you go to wendy's got a dollar
burger and some fries and a soda and sit
there and smoke cigarettes and wait six
hours until the club open and you're
starving now you gotta go in and you
know what it's amazing like hey you have
44 dollars for the holiday inn and the
club owner is like you got a place to
stay
now really you could stay at the condo
tonight just leave in the morning you're
like there you go i just saved 50 bucks
your life is an adventure
it's an adventure you don't there's some
days that don't work like that some days
you got to call western union and say
lisa put fifty dollars send it to
[ __ ] jacksonville florida
this western union what are you talking
about i need 50 [ __ ] dollars
do you want me to come home for
christmas yeah can you give me why
it's amazing it's amazing your life is
just
and you bump into people who will help
you out
you go to a town you do a show or comic
go say what are you gonna do nothing i'm
gonna drop what are you gonna drive for
i got a basement i got cable tv
nobody's home all day stay there watch
tv i got a computer you're like jesus i
just saved a hundred dollars
i just saved 150 [ __ ] dollars this
guy opened his home to me
and that's what happens
every day is different
you never got nervous about accepting
those offers of staying at someone's
house
comics were cool man okay so you worked
with them four days like you just
finished like i was in myrtle beach one
time
and i worked the weekend i was gonna
take a bus and this kid goes what are
you gonna take a bus for i'm driving
back to south carolina
where you're going is eight hours away
i go so what am i gonna do in charleston
he goes stay with me
i stayed with him for four [ __ ] days
the kid was a gentleman he gave me pizza
he worked at a pizza place he brought up
pizza
it was [ __ ] tremendous
you never know you never know until you
get out there
there's a girl that's around here
there's a girl that i forget what her
name is i just saw her comedy central
special
20 years ago we were in baltimore doing
a roger paul [ __ ] thievery gig
you know 400 when you get there it's 250
and there's no hotel
and her and her boyfriend will like stay
at our place it's right around the
corner
you have no idea they gave me a check so
i already had a round trip bus ticket i
couldn't cash a check at [ __ ]
midnight on a saturday night
so i was stuck they were like stay at
our house
the next morning i took the [ __ ] bus
back to new york
i still remember all these things
because they're miracles
but they wouldn't happen unless i made
the effort
do you understand me like i can't plan
that [ __ ] you can't plan that you i
don't know lisa would tell me to stay on
his couch
but unless i take getting that [ __ ]
car
and make the drive
you'll never know
you'll never [ __ ] know and that's
what stops people
they go i don't want to go out there
what if what if nothing get in the
[ __ ] car and drive
what if you run out of money who gives a
[ __ ] it'll work out
it'll work out just go out there i just
watched a very interesting movie
that i had never ever seen before
and it blew my mind i had to [ __ ]
come home and watch it again last night
till [ __ ] midnight really
wild
reese witherspoon when she backpacks
across and she's a hooker she's a [ __ ]
oh my my wife saw that my wife loved the
book loved the movie [ __ ] tremendous
[ __ ] tremendous she got nominated
unbelievable she gets [ __ ] in that
movie
800 times
there's one scene in the restaurant both
guys [ __ ] she's a waitress one guy
[ __ ] her from behind
but it's she's backpacking and she's
thinking of all these thoughts
and all these different situations and
there's a couple times when she gets in
the car with a guy and he goes you know
what uh i can't wait to take you home i
got a surprise for you and then she's
like i gotta meet my husband also the
guy takes her home he's got a wife and
she takes a shower and they feed her and
she hasn't eaten in days and the next
day the guy gives her a ride that [ __ ]
wouldn't happen
you wouldn't just find that you wouldn't
know the world has that to offer
unless you went for it that's the beauty
of you traveling
tom rhodes could tell all of us right
now tomorrow in the united states to
suck our dick he's got a complete
different family over in europe
he could be the real bulger you know the
[ __ ] guy that
johnny depp played
they would never find it
this [ __ ] they would never find
them
they would never find him they'd be
crazy to look for him because he could
he knows
he's created that over the years
he's created that it took seven eight
nine years to create this completely
different family
in singapore he could go to any town and
walk in and go
and [ __ ] chinese people were jumping
throwing duds
serving them a cat you know how it is
that's the beauty of that that you don't
know that
until you go out there and meet these
people
you don't find the beauty of people
that's the [ __ ] they don't tell you in
school
that's the [ __ ] that some authors
give you in their writing some authors
give you hope
you know what i'm going to go on the
road and i'm going to meet interesting
people well yeah i've read kerouac
there you go jack kerouac
absolutely san francisco
uh in 1990 i was like 22
and uh
that movie that book changed my life and
that's why i never was afraid of the
rose yeah you're never afraid you know
even uh
you know
i would say there's a quote in that book
he says i knew somewhere along the way
that the pearl would be handed to me
everything i needed to know everything i
wanted to experience
it's uh
i was always very scared about traveling
abroad even when i had the passport when
i had the passport i didn't take
advantage of it i was always very scared
i wanted to travel the united states
first
i pretty much done comedy everywhere you
know all these [ __ ] states except
maybe puerto rico that's it alaska i was
up there in choco charlie's you know
especially if you're drinking it's great
oh
and you're snorting and you wake up the
next morning you get a piece of halibut
you [ __ ] kidding me you could snort
80 pounds of bloat a piece of halibut
your back it don't matter what you're
saying it takes the electromagnesium out
of your body
the road is very interesting and when
people say it the road
it's this big you know in your mind if
you close your eyes it's
the road you know you just look at a
windshield and see this open road and
you're [ __ ] driving it
but it's got so many different things so
many lessons that i've learned but
mostly about people and the lesson i
learned the most it gave me hope in
mankind it gave me hope
and humanity because there's some
[ __ ] dynamite people out there
dynamite i wish i could name
all the [ __ ] cool people from day one
when i went to aspen that time
i met a white dude who used to be like
tom rhodes he was a brick mason
in the summers and in the winters he
would go to new zealand
and he had a complete different life
down there
and he would tell me about his life down
there and it was like a uh
magical too yeah being a kid and
somebody telling you these stories about
a far away land i was enamored with the
guy i couldn't believe it
and i would say you know and he we
exchanged numbers i used to
oh my god i forget the guy's name i did
masonry for
chip chilton he was a professional
[ __ ] skier
and he hired me to be a hottie carrier
and he hired me three [ __ ] summers
that dude two summers he hired me
he was a good dude but he worked your
ass off in the summer in the winter he
skied also he was a professional skier
but he was one of his uh
brick masons
and that always intrigued me that whole
and even then i was not even close to
being comic in 1983 it wasn't even a
dream but just that thought always
was like wow i'd like to get on a bus
and just go to california and hitchhike
back remember there was a show the
hitchhiker on hbo
oh i vacantly remember that there was a
show like the hitchhiker yeah that also
intrigued me he would always get his
dick sucked and have threesomes and [ __ ]
you know that would never happen to me
but it's a fantasy that the
the hitchhiker like you you had balls of
steel you [ __ ] when did you decide
you were leaving
really i i i was i don't remember making
a decision i went to i went to college
to be an editor and i knew emerson
emerson college in boston boston yeah uh
i just knew from the beginning that i
was coming out here i kind of wanted to
be in new york a little bit but i had a
job out here
so but it i did have i've told this
story but i had a panic attack in
connecticut because i realized that i
had everything in my entire life in my
car so i had to pull over for a second
and when i and when i came here
see i i've always turned people down i
feel bad when people are like when i
first came out here
my an editor offered to let me stay on
this couch while i found a place i was
like no and i paid for a hotel i just i
felt i always i don't want to intrude on
anybody
and like i can't tell you from this
podcast how many offers i've gotten
for anywhere and i always feel bad and i
always like
i don't know but it's i should start
accepting it more
i stayed on so many couches
that i can't anymore
like i refused it
yeah i did too i stayed on so many
[ __ ] couches i got so many free
nights
of rent
so many so [ __ ] many you know
people who said stay here i mean it was
just
unfucking believable so now
even when i go home people like take my
apartment whatever i'm like i'm [ __ ]
embarrassed i don't want to live in your
house
on vacation that's how i feel i want to
scratch my balls and i like to come home
for the comedy gig and drink coffee and
stay up for a while and listen to music
and write notes
you know it's awkward it's [ __ ]
awkward that's the i couldn't imagine
going to somebody's house and tiptoeing
through the house
two in the morning when i'm coming back
from doing comedy i'm a [ __ ] grown
man you know
and i did it so i was about 40 and then
i had to i just had to stop i just
stopped it it started would you i did it
a lot in the last 10 years and my wife
and i
uh like we rich all owns a ranch in
montana and we went and stayed there for
a month there's a guy a comedian invited
us to stay at his place in london
and uh he was a neurotic strange dude
so it was
like
we would throw away the he had the
garbage and recycling and you know so
anything plastic had to go into the
recycling so we're getting like you know
food from the grocery store
um
and put the plastic in the thing but he
would put the the plastic stuff in the
dishwasher and wash it before he put it
in the he had all these strange habits
so like sometimes you stay with somebody
and it's like they're weird and they're
irritating and then and then yeah like
you said you gotta you know tiptoe
around eggshells even if you got your
own separate room and stuff yeah i want
my own
respiratory [ __ ] place i want to
sleep by myself i don't want nobody in
the [ __ ] room watching me you know i
like to walk with my dick out no i like
people you know like i slept in people's
houses and all of a sudden you wake up
with coke around your nose with a sleep
apnea machine and that four-year-old's
poking you with a stick
or [ __ ] running a hot wheel through
your [ __ ] stomach because your
stomach's hanging out of your shirt
you have no [ __ ] idea i have my
friend's dog pissed on me when i was
sleeping one time because my hand was
hanging off the edge and he was pissed
on the edge of the [ __ ] couch and i
got pissed on my face and on my arm by a
[ __ ] pug that's why i don't like
[ __ ] bugs
i hate those [ __ ] dogs so
that's why it was just it just got old
man
you know i've lived with people up to
1993.
i lived with george in new york and i
said [ __ ] this i went back to boulder
and i got an apartment i stayed there by
myself i'm 95. then after 95 you know
bam i've been on my own pretty [ __ ]
much
i i
love living alone it's it's great like i
i've thought about living with people
and it just it's terrible it's so much
better living alone they touch you well
i mean
having a place to live is a new concept
for me i mean i just we just got an
apartment here six months ago
you know from not living anywhere
and every week going to a different city
you know to different you know hotels
mostly
um and then when we had time off we
would take a epic vacation my wife and i
we went to rome the last four years and
stuff um two years ago we went to bali
when i was still drinking we would go to
new orleans a lot
um so depending where i was in the
planet so uh you know my wife and i just
the fact we have an apartment now like
we're like you know to have like a
a sock drawer and an underwear drawer
and like just the simplest things
you know make us happy like we open the
refrigerator man i'm like you know these
are our condiments i own that mustard
it's like it's it's kind it's really new
and like i said my i have uh this
massive book collection and my vinyl
records i'm just playing my vinyl
records
to start the day every day
it's awesome
to have stuff you don't have the tv
which is interesting i have a tv but uh
i just netflix on it i don't watch
regularly don't watch it
yeah just just netflix [ __ ] those
[ __ ] yeah
if i had no responsibilities like i've
been thinking about i think it would be
really cool
to just be an uber driver and just drive
across the country i've had some
incredible conversations with uber
drivers
in los angeles some of them are cool
some of them were kind of like like i've
had some weird ones but i think it was
just like
every city i've never been in new
orleans once
i would love to check out all those
places and i think i just like
especially if you're partying man it
never closes
and um one of the cities that's scared
new orleans and you and i met in houston
houston and uh you know like i said i
stopped doing uh hard drugs a couple
years ago and uh stopped drinking but i
do have to give a commercial to
houston
and new orleans as the purest cocaine of
anywhere in america
i mean the the dealers really have an
appreciation for the original product
and uh
i mean that should be advertised on
their you know uh tourist propaganda
that they don't step on their [ __ ] my
time give me a pen over there
give me a pen over there let me see
my towns
for cocaine in this order
well
el paso
totally
el paso
houston and new orleans i think those
are my top three
new orleans
and then miami el paso really there was
one other place in there what's the one
that's 10 hours from houston
but midland
midland texas
which is around the corner from el paso
a few hours i i did a gig there one
that's where i showed up and the [ __ ]
mc gave me an eight ball he gave me an
eight ball and the featuring eight ball
and he had an eight ball and at the end
of the show he had done his eight ball
already it was [ __ ] crazy it was
[ __ ] crazy but el paso
that was
i'm lucky i didn't dine el paso was it
like the quality you know the quality so
good quantity how much of it oh yeah
who's did it who had it
it was always available it was always
one night listen to me a guy and i i did
something
and this guy just happened to see it
like it could have been a commercial
or like a co-star on a tv show this had
to be
2001 2000 because it was the old comic
strip
the old comic strip
because they were here and then they
moved across the street he bought the
building and that's where it ended once
he bought the building he was here for
20 years and made a [ __ ] small gold
mine then he moved the q he fired the
game manager he did all these moves that
were stupid here it was a gold mine it
was tuesday through saturday my god it
was just [ __ ] craziness and the
cocaine was la pied de la resistance the
first time i went was fourth of july
90 [ __ ] seven i came back to shoot
that
first time i went to el paso it was july
of 97 and i came back to shoot a [ __ ]
taco bell commercial with the dog
remember those first commercials the dog
i shot the first three
but i came back and i brought back a
coke rocker on the bus
and i got on the bus i sat down i did
two [ __ ] bumps and within an hour
they pulled the bus over and the dogs
are getting on i crushed the rock up i
slaught the whole thing by the time they
got to me i had my t-shirt off i was
sweating profusion
i had a bead running down my armpit
[ __ ] classic [ __ ] that's the first so
once i had that experience i'm like i'm
going back there
and it took me like two years to go back
there but when i got back there
it was lights out
light that was another place that the
original condo all night long people be
knocking
you want to buy any coke you're like uh
yeah come on in i was just thinking
about making a call but i didn't really
you know that was nothing i was like del
paso i had one of the greatest moments
in my career in el paso at the comic
strip at the comic strip it was about
five years ago
this massive snow storm it never snows
never snows i was there in february this
massive snowstorm hits el paso and i
mean it was it was [ __ ] [ __ ] and they
were having rolling blackouts like the
night before the the show had been
canceled because uh the electricity had
blacked out in the whole city on and off
so
i love del pot i i love el paso because
it's it's all you know 80 percent
mexican people there's the audience and
then there's an army base there fort
bliss so you got about 20 of the
audiences like army people and stuff so
the great audiences and
uh i was on stage for about a half hour
and i was killing because any comedian
that tells a story about himself is
killing in the story
i'm doing a great set
the lights go out the the
the city blacked out while i was on
stage and
the people in the audience held up their
cell phones and i did another
half hour in the glow of cell phone
light with no electricity it was really
cool they were like no no man keep going
[ __ ] it
your [ __ ] was their phone not their
noses glowing from the cocoa well i
guess they were cooked they were like
they're ready they didn't want to end
the good time right they weren't cold i
could lie to you and tell you a bunch of
stories and i can tell you that i cut my
comedy teeth in texas
if it wasn't for the state of texas
i wouldn't even become a comic texas has
always been because they gave me the
freedom to say what the [ __ ] i wanted
they had tons of work
no matter what city in that [ __ ]
beautiful state you've always got work
i love texas too always throughout my
career i've always i can't always
you know what i don't work the comic
strip no more just because i just don't
you know it's just uh bart's a great guy
he does what he does
but i don't know i can't lie to you
either i used to work that club as a
feature
four or five times a year yeah i i'd
bust it down there bust it right now
monday night eleven o'clock bus get you
in that one in the afternoon i'd stay up
all night on the bus talking [ __ ] by
myself with an ipod
writing stupid [ __ ] jokes i'd bring
sandwiches
and i [ __ ] ride the bus get that one
go to the condo take a nap
take a shower
do the show on [ __ ] tuesday night and
that's when it starts it was tuesday
wednesday thursday
two friday and two saturday it was a
long week jack seven shows and the six
of those nights you snorted up a [ __ ]
blizzard
you saw daylight every night do you
understand me you saw a daylight
every night in el paso if you want it
means you stayed up until the morning
daylight 7 a.m [ __ ] go to bed i don't
give a [ __ ] who i worked that [ __ ]
room but they knew
this room this [ __ ] condo is going to
be rocking until daylight
i swear to god that was so crazy down
there and you know
uh it's a shame i and down the block
they had a supermarket
and on friday mornings they used to make
yucatan fish soup
with every piece of [ __ ] fish
available and you see like eyeballs and
heads
and shark fins and [ __ ] let me tell you
something no matter how much some coke
used doing it tonight before or how bad
that [ __ ] was the eight
the next morning all you had to add was
that yucatan fish soup
and you were back in business that
brought you back for friday you went
back took a nap till about 6 30
went down to the comic strip had that
cheeseburger and went on stage and did
two shows and got another package
it was cr and then they had a chick that
delivered blow to you
and she had a boyfriend from time to
time you could talk to licking your nuts
because she was so cooked up by the end
this was craziness then you had dallas i
got coked up a few times
the other place was crazy midland that
was that was run by a magician that was
horrible and he was married so he was
yeah rob jenkins and robert jacobs i did
that gig he brought me in there for new
year's eve once we're like
i was like it was like four grand or
something it was crazy this place
it was a place next door that did
norteno dancing it
is this dance and this music that's only
in the north of mexico
so
you know really cowboy mexican people
there was a really grimy strip club in
that town did you go there no it was
like total nudity no no no and like uh
you know um they worked for tips or
something the kids crying in the back
and [ __ ] the kid had dead kids stabbing
themselves and [ __ ] the little [ __ ]
affluenza white kids there jumping up
and down [ __ ] you
those strip clubs are hard you get shot
in those [ __ ] strip clubs they don't
even have floors it's dirt it's like the
inside of a [ __ ] barn would stay this
is crazy because they had one
and uh in fact babbitt took me to the
one that was a barn down where selena's
from
down in corpus [ __ ] christie
you're not serious in a barn
of the animals there was no animals the
animals had been killed
they had been transferred to a different
farm and they had a strip club and a
barn they had four chicks dancing they
had like a roulette table this had to be
me freddy soto and somebody else i loved
freddy's so this had to be god bless his
soul this had to be
20
1999 me freddie and in those days i used
to pull a scam
i used to because they wanted like
a ton of money to fly into houston
direct
but if you flew into houston via san
antonio or something
you get off the plane in san antonio
[ __ ] tremendous for like 99 bucks i
get off the plane in san antonio and
[ __ ] and take the bus down from san
antonio to corpus christi like a puerto
rican you know me doug
how much money would you say you were
doing that i can't imagine you're doing
that now and then i'd go back to corpus
and they'd fight with me they'd say no
this isn't your destination i make up a
story and now you can't do that
what do you mean you make of a
destination because you have to fly out
of you can't fly to the connecting city
so let's say i have a ticket from dallas
to phoenix to l.a
and i show up in phoenix an hour before
the flight they're not going to let me
out there's not today there's not
actually this dude got in trouble this
dude yeah they they don't [ __ ] around
they lost he they the guys the the
airlines i'm pretty sure lost the suit
because he made it i'm all i can check
but he made a website where you do that
you save money by just getting off or
getting on at like a weird uh connecting
flight but i'm pretty sure he beat the
airlines at least united
what are you gonna do you know what i'm
saying flying that it was tony bennett
cox
it's monday night
february 1st get your ducks in order
it's a new [ __ ] month
it's amazing
for somebody
are you recording or is this a break
we're recording
because i told you my vinyl records i'm
playing tons of ella fitzgerald records
sinatra tony bennett it's [ __ ] great
that's all i'm listening to now love
tony bennett
i
lee i want you to know something i've
always been a hard-headed guy
so
i i was you know i came from cuba
you had the [ __ ] 45s okay and they
had a thing in the middle and you played
45s okay
everybody was [ __ ] happy
everybody was [ __ ] happy
everybody was [ __ ] happy
albums were great people were smoking
dope people were having a good time
you had two other things excuse me you
had eight tracks
and you had cassettes
but vinyl was the way to [ __ ] go and
all of a sudden some genius said no
let's go real to real
so all of a sudden all these [ __ ] joe
jerk off started going real real did you
you really real yet no
no
no no i knew at [ __ ] 18 in 1982
i kept saying to myself this is a scam
did people really have reel the reels in
their hands really real in the house my
friend still has it in this basement no
he doesn't yes he does he's the only one
that fell for it he found him and three
other idiots all got real real
you know we hear judas priests we could
hear rob halford's voice pull away
they all had a thousand [ __ ] stories
remember when cds came out it was like
being here it's like being in the room
being in the room with them
you know it's always some [ __ ] story
and people fell for and i kept saying to
myself this is great
this is just great why they gotta [ __ ]
with something i always felt that
and then there was something else that
happened music music in general and
every year you know
you had to [ __ ] i remember still
having the walkman
with the power booster
i went to a store in new york uh
[ __ ] it was like all they did was sell
appliances
and i went there and they actually had
the [ __ ] power booster so i had a
power booster connected to a [ __ ]
equalizer so it could be loud as [ __ ]
connected to like state-of-the-art
[ __ ] speakers you know
then everything changed now we got to
put the thing in it and then they came
out with the [ __ ] ipod so me and my
walkman have to go [ __ ] themselves right
yeah all over again you know what i have
in my stores
because i saved them i got a cassette uh
a walkman and i got a i got two cd disc
men jesus and uh
you know
the when the ipod came out
everyone got rid of their music
collection remember everybody had
thousands of cds i still got mine
because i had it in storage you know but
uh
you know this is the new thing so like
everybody got the ipods
got rid of their music collections they
don't even [ __ ] sell i got two ipods
they don't sell those anymore and one of
my ipods is broke that you can't take it
to an apple store and get it fixed
so like i mean now everybody downloads
music and [ __ ] but like
uh
you know
what happened even the ipod is outdated
like that that thing right there that
speaker
that's a [ __ ] ipod uh
charger
yeah that's an ipod charger ralphie may
gave me that for christmas 10 [ __ ]
years ago to charge your ipod the only
reason why it's down here is because on
my last trip to vegas i lost my [ __ ]
ipod
all right i just lost it i just filled
it up with songs i put the sabbath
collection
ufo i had some tony bennett yeah i put
two sinatra albums
that's mine with music is the screen is
broke where can you get a screen fixed
on a ipod lancashire boulevard really
yeah they have because this guy like my
entire music collection is on this one
fat eyebrow it's about 100 bucks oh man
but they'll put the screen on a few
hours right here listen those armenians
they'll do anything really on [ __ ]
north hollywood right next to the old
haha
they fix ipod and screens and if not
next to uh
what's the puerto rican place on
lancashire
up there they got a [ __ ] place right
next door to it they'll fix it while you
wait cool that's how much they got into
a science that whole [ __ ] screen on
the thing
but
so [ __ ] thursday i'm leaving for
charlotte
i gotta wake up at three in the goddamn
morning
i gotta leave the house at four
get at the airport at five
i get in the car at four i make a
protein shake with a [ __ ] banana
i take my uh whatever [ __ ] pill
then i take my blood pressure medication
and i smoke some dope
and i this is my first road gig in
months
in a month and a half since december
14th i haven't driven to lax since
the first week of december might take a
break yeah i always take a break [ __ ]
that there's no reason for me to travel
because i'm dirty so in december it's
kind of weird for me
so i try to just do local gigs i don't
want to get caught in the [ __ ] snow
i don't want to be one of those [ __ ]
that people watch on tv and say look at
those [ __ ] stuck in an airport
i never want to be one of those guys i
[ __ ] hate it
i hate it i [ __ ] hate it
i hate people who do it i'm going home
for the holidays good luck yeah
somewhere you're gonna get [ __ ] in the
ass you know
and uh
what were you talking about i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm talking about him so
high right now
what are we talking about uh ipods music
oh yeah yeah yeah you got on the car i
gotta get in the [ __ ] car i puke i
get caught sick i miss the exit
i'm basically driving on the 405 oh this
is when you went to charlotte just last
thursday
right so i'm driving on the 405 and i
have all the windows open
i have the air conditioner blast i got
the music off
and i've got the seat like this and i'm
driving like this with my eyes closed
guys and last night open up and i see
century boulevard like i had slept
through the [ __ ] exit i was so
[ __ ] busy
i got off on the 105 somewhere and i
made a ride on the science and by the
grace of god i got back on the century
within 10 minutes
at that left onto the century i could
feel the rumblings i started farting
those really bad anxiety farts that come
out of the ass
i'm driving down century i'm doing 90
and i'm crisscrossing like i got a dui
i'm surprised we're still having this
[ __ ] conversation i just didn't get
out of jail i get into the airport
there's no traffic i get the terminal
four it's american airlines
and as i get the ticket it just exits
out of my mouth onto that thing i gotta
pull over finish up the puke it's on my
[ __ ] shirt wow there's a banana in
the car from the [ __ ] blender that
didn't blend all the way
i gotta take my shirt off throw it in
the [ __ ] garbage and take a shirt out
of the luggage and put that in that's
how i flew i walked to the [ __ ]
airport i'm barely walking in there i'm
purple i'm purple i swear to god guys i
should have canceled no i didn't i went
through security it was quick
for the first time ever it wasn't gate
44d which is always always at the end it
was gate 60 the first one over and i sat
there and i look up and i'm breathing
i'm taking my hooded sweatshirt off i'm
just breathing i'm getting dizzy i look
over and i see [ __ ] sandwiches and
water and i walk over there i i don't
even know how i did it i bought the
water and drank and sat down
that brought me back a little bit and
then i went and got a turkey sandwich
with avocado and arugula and that took
me down a level and i bought it the
[ __ ] plane and i was fine
was it the protein shake i don't know
what it was i think it was the reefer
and the [ __ ] nicotine gum i think it
took me to a different level you know
what i'm saying i've been having
problems with medication lately a few
weeks ago i was reframing nyquist that's
frightening man you're like jesus christ
i did black and edible
don't ever eat an edible and do
nightcrawl jack
i thought i was gonna die in the morning
i'm afraid of the edibles i had some
cookies last year it was like it was
like waiting for an illness to pass
some of this [ __ ] you know i just you
know you just came in los angeles some
of this edible [ __ ] frightening you just
can't even half a gummy bear and you're
like you know no no no no we're not
gumming it up tonight i'm gonna meet him
tomorrow too i gotta meet him sometime
lee might have to even go meet him
that's how busy you might not even have
to go because he can only come at 11
o'clock tomorrow my man from force one
star is
bringing it in so we go deep this week
with dick syed his dad's coming from
florida he loves me i'm from florida he
loves the stars of death my cousin is a
is a cop in boynton beach there you go
next time you get pulled over he's got a
friend in boynton beach
see how it works out i had a thing
happen to me i was driving to the
airport i was in orlando for the
holidays and when i was leaving
i went
to get to the orlando airport i've been
there a million times but i came at it
from a different direction i was on this
like turnpike thing and or or
this expressway i missed my exit and
somehow i got thrown onto the florida
turnpike and this has never happened i'm
from orlando i've been to the airport a
million times
and
i was running a little late i mean i had
to you know i drop off this rent-a-car
and then make it to the airport my
flight's like it's 7 am so this is like
already like whatever it is 5 30 5 45
i'm cutting it way too close and i'm
about to be thrown onto
the florida turnpike heading towards
miami so
it looked like the only thing to do
there was this
like it looked like
about the size of a a curb and then
about the width of a sidewalk uh this
kind of median between where
this on-ramp to the off-ramp that was
going the opposite way
and
i drove over this and i had this little
tiny prius
and it like it kind of got stuck
on the uh the sidewalk length was about
how much it is between the tires or
whatever i'm like kind of so i really
rocked this car and like i'm flooring
the gas and then finally like it it gets
over and it's like smoking and you could
just you could just you could hear just
that crunch bottom out i made it over
the thing get into this other lane and
the guy sitting there at the money
collecting booth dude
i go what which what do you want me to
pay you and he goes well you have to pay
it's five from the last xr five bucks
sure give him the five bucks made it
dropped off the car
and uh and made it to my flight in time
so um that's always why you should get
full coverage on the rent-a-car jesus
christ so you can do [ __ ] like god's
shame on you for renting had i not
gotten full coverage
you get hit the car blows up and [ __ ]
you die from electric shock and [ __ ]
oh my god i hate those but what we've
had to go through to make it to flights
to get to gigs
sometimes it's a [ __ ] nightmare
that's why i leave her the first flight
out always
really yeah you like those early flights
yeah it gets it out of the way and i'm
there that's it i don't have to go in
the night before and waste time
i get out of lax at five in the morning
if i have to
that's the first flight out to most of
these cities so it gives me a jump i get
it even on the east coast i can have
lunch time but one
five o'clock get you there when i get
out of la when i get out of new york i
get that quarter the sixth flight ooh
on a sunday gets you back at 8 30 a.m
like a doctor you drive up that 405 like
you own it you're the only one on there
you know i'm saying there's nobody on
there i land at two i gotta drive
another hour after i get home
i know i'm 53. i got one for the great
one a banana peel
i think i got two hours to drive with a
[ __ ] 405 and [ __ ] people don't get
that and they get mad when i tell them
listen i'm not going down they wanted me
to go down wednesday and meet these
people and i'm like listen let me tell
you let me tell you about my life i
leave thursday when i leave on thursday
i don't go over the hill because i only
got [ __ ]
uh three days the baby goes to school
tomorrow so that gives me a little grace
tomorrow and
wednesday it's good because mondays i
got the kid the kid you don't know when
she's gonna fall asleep
i don't know what detail my wife has to
do so i don't really have a schedule if
it's an envelope yeah then we have to go
pick up an envelope but i don't know
envelope you want to talk to me about a
movie i could wait
you could wait because i have the baby i
don't know when i'm going to see the
fight you know what i'm saying so i just
mondays i chill
i really take it easy on mondays unless
it's an audition or i gotta go it's
something positively absolutely like
federal express if not i try to keep it
light today i had a few dumb things
walter even were wasting my [ __ ] time
thank god i got the work out there you
know what i'm saying look at you lisa
yeah looking good
bold your eyeballs are [ __ ] high as
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i was like when you guys
were talking about those gigs i used to
go to some of those like hotel gigs and
it's like
i used to love finding a new comedian
like i was taught i was emailing back
and forth with this guy he said he went
to a midnight show and some of the
comics weren't that good i said yeah but
it isn't really fun when you find a new
comedian to like like as a comic is it
fun for you to like go around to all
these places and find new good comments
yeah definitely but i i like that you
say that like just being the fan of it
and then cheering for a guy yeah i mean
you know i'm sure you as well
meet young guys and you know they're
going to be great comedians
even if they have no self-esteem and
they they they live in the middle of
nowhere um
certain people
i mean and then other people develop and
then it clicks for people later in life
and you know you definitely
make friends with comedians and you're
you're cheering for them you know and
then other people have you know um
addiction hang-ups that they have to
navigate
it's
no yeah it's it's i know comedians all
over the world man i you know i wanted
to do this show where
i'm the anthony bourdain of comedy
because i do these shows comedy all
around the world so i wanted to
go around the world check out uh
highlight comedy scenes or check out
comedy scenes highlight comedians from
those places and then also see what
people are making jokes about in other
countries
there's all these gigs in asia now
and i was in hanoi last year i went to
vietnam 20 years ago when i did viva
vietnam
for comedy central i went there and did
this hour special where i you know uh
went all over vietnam
and uh
had fun for the guys we didn't get to
have fun whatever
so it was the first time i had been back
in 20 years and they have stand up now
and this young comedian in hanoi opened
up for me he's 19 years old his all-time
comedy hero is eddie murphy delirious
so this guy
he's 19 he's just been on comedy for a
couple months
but everything he delivers is like eddie
murphy and delirious because that's his
his hero
you know when you're on your scooter
and your girl is on the back
and you're driving through town like you
know he's got no material he's a young
comedian but you know the guy he's in
hanoi
and he's you know he loves comedy loves
eddie murphy you know i mean how are you
not gonna fall in love with a guy like
that and cheer for him comedy's
everywhere now gabriel was telling me a
story about going to
you know somewhere where we're supposed
to be at war with them
gabriel went somewhere he said the
people were [ __ ] tremendous that they
were saying when you go back to america
tell them what we're really like well
not these people that they portraying
the media and the one guy said i want to
be a stand-up comic so gabriel went and
watched him do comedy and he goes it was
[ __ ] hysterical
you know just to see other cultures what
the hell they're talking about i just
worked with a kid
this weekend his last name was patel i
worked with two really good comics
uh
and the patel kid was killing me
was killing me friday night talking
about muhammad and all this [ __ ] you
know it's just great to see comics
starting out it does something to you
and now that you're not drinking you
really connect
now that you see i did a tony henry's
show and i was telling lee that that
night i saw something in their faces
that guys like you and i used to have
at that five year mark that acceptance
there's a part where you can accept it
as a comic like somebody above you
accepts you that just brings a different
type of thrill to your soul when
somebody says hey come on let's go have
a drink that's it
you're [ __ ] you but you've arrived
you know and you're having a drink with
this guy and you ask him about talking
jokes and he offers you to take you to
minneapolis whatever
that's what this whole thing is really
about sometimes you know and some yeah
you're right some of us have drug issues
i mean i'm very lucky
i did not die on the road you know very
lucky
i'm very lucky i didn't die in [ __ ]
beaumont
i
there was a lot of nights boy that were
[ __ ] ugly across this country
that would have been horrible to go into
a hotel room to find me you know and uh
i'm really happy i didn't go out that
way we're all gonna [ __ ] die but we
all could choose yeah i did not want to
die like jim morrison i did not want to
die like that
there had to be something better for us
and i'm happy it's behind us now
i'm happy it's really like i did i will
tell you one thing
i only slept three hours on [ __ ]
saturday night so i get on the plane
there's 23 [ __ ] on the plane
i'm upgraded two times to first class
i gave me one seat they gave me two
i'm sitting there by myself i get on the
plane
the breakfast was phenomenal it was a
french toast souffle that i had on the
way there i usually don't eat french
toast or take the chance but i was
already sick french toast souffle the
little little [ __ ] nut with a little
syrup tremendous they gave me a little
fruit cup the toot
and a [ __ ] biscuit that was dry and
in debt i thought i was on [ __ ]
papillon island
unfucking believable american headlines
upgrade you first class the biscuit was
dried and dick okay
happy on cracker oh yeah the [ __ ]
papillon cracker
what was i talking about american allies
no [ __ ] movie
but uh
let me tell you what i had gentlemen
i went deep
i had no reefer
i usually have like a pill or two in my
luggage you know i'm saying there's
always something in my
luggage i'm one of those dudes you look
deep there's always something it looks
like a blood pressure medication it
could be a half of xanax or something
i looked through that luggage at the
hotel there was nothing
i was so like on the plane i took a
little nappy noodle for about an hour
i heard the pilot get back on okay we're
back on track we got about four hours
and four hours no movie i said [ __ ] it i
called the lady oh i said listen do me a
favor let me get two
let me get the doers and ginger ale
what was the last time you had doings
and ginger ale i could never drink
scotch gotcha so i could never handle it
it's just christ
this [ __ ] wedge comes back and she
goes i don't know if i told you you got
upgraded twice so i'm bringing you two
bottles oh [ __ ] when somebody brings you
two bottles out right you gotta go lisa
and i sat there like a doctor and i
poured the [ __ ] scotch in first i let
the scotch collaborate with the [ __ ]
ice cubes you know what i'm saying to
get that boldness bitterness away
then i dropped the ginger ale in a
little increments like a jew you know
i'm saying like a jew in the desert just
[ __ ] i just bubbled up
and then i gave it another minute and i
put the stair in and i took the stick i
stuck the stair in an ice cube and i ate
the ice cube but just the [ __ ]
with that
on it you know i'm saying not a lot of
[ __ ] live like that i love the
image of you doing this by yourself oh
my god like a doctor
like a doctor when i look to my left
there was nobody in those seats so i was
scratching my nuts through my jeans i
was picking my nose i had i was having a
party over there
usually i gotta go to your bathroom and
scratch your nuts [ __ ] no i just popped
that zipper down and stuck that arm in
there
if you caught me thought i was fingering
myself i was scratching those nuts like
adopted did you under the the the button
on your jeans i didn't do it a couple of
times no no no no no no no you didn't do
that no i just opened up my zip and
stuck my hand and scratched my balls
i [ __ ] pick snots on my nose i was
over there by myself there was one lady
behind me she was passed out
i had those two [ __ ] scotches and i
[ __ ] passed out guys
20 minutes before the plane landed i got
up like i was feeling [ __ ] tremendous
scotch ain't bad listen
scotch is not bad if you drink it two of
those [ __ ] 33. my dad used to
drink rusty nails scotch and drambuie
jesus [ __ ] i take a little sip off
the top just that top part was nice um
you know what bryce but scotch
with [ __ ] rusty nails that's when you
know what's a rusty nail scotch scotch
and dram buoy
my dad taught me how to gasoline with
gasoline from the time i was like
10 or 12 my dad taught me how to make it
for him perfectly and so i've i i spent
my whole life making him
uh rusty nails back in the back in the
day that was my [ __ ] rusty nails i liked
for a long time i drank crown and ginger
that was that was always a couple bless
what was your favorite drink of choice
and you did a couple of blasts before
you went to the beer because after a
while that alcohol burns right through
you so once you go before you went to
the beer well back in the coke was
probably
crown and ginger
ground yeah that's a good one i always
like vodka and anything vodka was like
what the supermodels drink because it
has
less sugar and you know uh i always
loved vodka vodka's straight on the ice
probably i tried too much vodka as a kid
to like it as an adult
well vodka goes with anything also with
gatorade anything you can mix vodka with
[ __ ]
drinks perverse baby food
is [ __ ] gonna work in a quarter vodka
with iced tea and then going home
passing out getting up in the middle
and there'd be iced tea in the picture
and you drink the iced tea you want to
vomit because that's what you were just
drinking with the oh my god i got a
story for you man i was in san francisco
years ago and partying all night in my
hotel room and all these
people over from the club
waitresses and comedians and
we were up drinking tons of vodka and
partying anyway uh i woke up in the next
day and i was totally hungover and i
made coffee and uh i i i had there was a
cup
next to the bed i was just hungover and
it's probably still half [ __ ] up i
threw the cup of water in there and then
uh i i made the coffee and you know
little tiny hotel coffee machine and
then i took a sip and it was it was
vodka
and coffee
what i made
and so i i took the sip and i was like
oh [ __ ] that's vodka
that i made the coffee with and then so
i thought to myself wait a minute this
could be like the next peanut butter and
jelly or about reese's peanut butter cup
remember the old commercial guy's
walking with the chocolate bar in the
park he trips goes into the girl's
jar of peanut butter how sexual was that
commercial you know but so that's like
how peanut butter that's all these
peanut butter cups were invented so like
i thought oh maybe i'll give this a try
so i took another sip and it is
definitely not the new reese's paint
over here but if you put cream in that
[ __ ]
you could have saved this yeah you don't
put it out i should have done it you're
gonna smoke crack and you put in the
microwave oven and it don't come back
when that happens listen when you put
like you know like let's say somebody
comes over with a gram and they want to
cook it up right
they throw some coconut throw some
microwave in there normal monday
who's trying to teach sleep just in case
let's say you take a coffee cup lee and
somebody comes over with a g bowler root
that's how you tell if the coke is good
you throw it in the water you put three
fingers of water in the cup you throw
the coke in the water and then you throw
like a tent or maybe two tenths of
baking soda and you put the microwave
for 30 seconds
you put that in there when that
[ __ ] goes bing you take that
thing out and there'll be some particles
flowing and you take those chunks out
and you let it dry
and you look at it and that should be a
gram of coke
because if the coke was good it should
be maybe nine tenths if the coke was
really good if it's fugazi coke
you get back like five tenths and you
piss [ __ ] off but there's people who
could throw that back in there they were
like houdini a couple puerto ricans do
it a couple of weird people like
colombia's they throw some baking soda
and more baking soda and you take more
back
so these guys know how to throw more
baking soda than that put in there for
like 10 seconds bing they take it out
and they take like an extra two tenths
back a lot of people don't know that
might as well drop it on you right now
on a monday night where else you're
gonna get this kind of knowledge where
else you're gonna get this kind of
knowledge how to bring back coke you
know what i'm saying you never smoked a
piece of coke
anyway oh i tried it years ago [ __ ] yeah
houston texas [ __ ]
houston was my favorite
houston was one of those places i should
have died at yeah and that's even
without exaggerating
i would eat like a [ __ ] animal i
would drink like a [ __ ] animal yeah i
was sleeping i worked with you in
houston yeah please a couple times i
worked with you
i did that [ __ ] room i did it with
hedberg
that was that was when you guys brought
comedy to houston that was when
houston people knew there was something
[ __ ] big happen here
when you had come back to do that
co-headlining spot with hedberg i still
remember that that was like what
what are you saying
what the [ __ ] are they saying hedberg
and this [ __ ] yeah they both took
less money too yeah just so we could
work together just because we loved
hanging out so wait joey did you open
for tom yeah so how many people do you
have relationships with like this we're
like d like 20 years later 10 years
later you guys are friends
and this is what comedy is that's crazy
you know he could disappear for three
years he comes back i bump into him i
give him a hug we talk [ __ ] we smoke a
number we don't smoke a number i got a
lot of photos and i got those out of
storage also and i just
looked through i i got to look back
through them more deeply but like i got
tons of photos of of you and us that
week
and uh it's it's it's remarkable because
you know i don't feel old but look at
those photos like man you and i like we
look you look young and
i got head shots done about a month ago
i haven't even developed him
every time i open it i go jesus christ
what happens like what really happened
and lately i've been doing the math on
my friends you know some of these guys
i talked to a girl tell you that
legitimately i know 40 years
when you know somebody 40 years you're
[ __ ] old jack
you're [ __ ] old okay you know i mean
that's it this is it
this is it you know
and like i said a thousand times like i
loved growing up in jersey i loved my
neighborhood i loved those people
i loved where i grew up in conjunction
in new york city i was able to just take
a bus and be in the city in eight
minutes that doesn't exist no more the
traffic is [ __ ] quadruple since then
but i always start like i said you know
i always thought that one day i would
close my eyes and go back to north
bergen and everything would be the way
it was
all my friends would still be at the bar
snorting blow
listen to bruce springsteen you know
whatever and that doesn't even exist
that doesn't even exist these guys are
christians or whatever the [ __ ] yeah i
do now and uh
my one buddy works at ups and uh you
know
it's dead like that's it this is it
we're in the final [ __ ] countdown tom
rhodes and we love it i love it
how do i feel i feel like i'm [ __ ]
dirty yeah because i'm living how a 30
year old should live you know i'm trying
to live drink a lot of water get sleep
no drugs a little bit of reefer
you know yeah that's the [ __ ] recipe
what else
reefer some fish
shoot that [ __ ] sperm out of your
helmet twice three times a week [ __ ]
man it sounds like we're on the same
diet yeah all you need to do is give
blood once a month like an ounce so you
like
16 ounces you give blood once a month
you're a [ __ ] new man once every two
months your heart makes that new [ __ ]
blood your stomach it gets harder you
get that old brown blood out of your
helmet you give blood once a month i try
i go down to the doctor's office and i
make up some bogus excuse i'm getting
dizzy
so they take blood out of my [ __ ] arm
saying four ounces whatever the [ __ ]
they take but that makes your body make
new blood you know
something
some water some garlic
bam you got a whole new dose of [ __ ]
blood you know i'm saying you're a
vampire is [ __ ] fine yeah i feel like
you just made all that up i think i did
but it works for me in my head
somebody once told me that that's why
women don't die a heart attack since
they bleed once a month
and it makes a lot of sense
is that true
well
that's why women don't how many women
you know who [ __ ] punch the ticket
while they're [ __ ] roller skating
they shovel the snow not too many guys
always die showing snow and [ __ ]
women waking up and putting their shoes
on and [ __ ] why i think i don't put my
shoes on in the morning no more i have
mercy do it i get like a dollar in a
little bank account
i don't put my shoes on that's bad luck
you got to find somebody to put your
shoes on that's success
anybody anybody bedtime that's great
that's fantastic
you know charlie chaplin never wore the
same pair of socks twice after he got
famous because he was so poor when he
was a kid he never wanted to
wear the same pair of socks twice
that was his those things that's the
team took me he just dropped on me
though
that's cool i think so like real success
would be having somebody put your shoes
on for you imagine yeah just sitting
back everything that's emperor [ __ ] and
bringing a balance like put your shoes
on they cut your toenails first put
cream on your feet
then put your socks on make sure the top
is all tight you know you always [ __ ] up
and leave the top rolled over they make
sure they rub your caffeine [ __ ] loosen
up the blood then they put the shoe in
for you that's success
that's what i need somebody to do that
roll joints
you know what i'm saying don't talk much
you don't know the language something
you know because that's all you can't
find somebody white to rub your calves
and put your shoes who do you think
would be the best at it it had to be for
somebody from another country somewhere
oh yeah what country but somebody would
be co somebody would be cool like
somebody who would be knowledgeable
maybe he was on the run for murdering
somebody in bulgaria or something yeah
he wants to come here rub people's feet
i don't [ __ ] know you know what i'm
saying why you put me on the spot like
i'm trump or something like that
you know it'd be like the least worst
thing you said like you think someone's
gonna be a good joint ruler that's not
bad for you
dog somebody somewhere has a joint role
a snoop dogg [ __ ] yes i heard years ago
who was it um a friend of mine told me
and this was
jesus i don't know 30 years ago it's got
to be total horseshit they said that was
it kevin costner or
one of those actors had or no maybe it
was
[ __ ] don't throw nobody under the bus
unless you know for sure okay kevin
costa's got to turn no what's his name
the guy uh han solo what's it uh
louie hook me up here harrison ford
right oh yeah harrison ford kevin
costner one of those guys like that this
friend of mine yeah and the friend who
told me was non-show business person so
i don't even know how he would know but
it just seems cool he said that he had a
joint roller and that was the guy's job
to just make sure that he always had a
joint ready and the dude's name was
sloane so whenever he wanted to join he
would say sloane
i heard that like [ __ ] 30
years ago it might not even might not
even be true
i know for a fact that
the pharmacy
in hollywood 10 15 years ago when this
whole wheat thing they would close at 7
and somebody want to ask him why do you
close at 7 30 and say he goes because at
8 7 30 is when
uh harrison ford were coming with
calista flockhart
and they would cop weed down there i
don't even know if the pharmacies are
still around no one of them closed there
was one in venice that was the hot spot
for wheat you know how much i was
dropping there a month guys
how much
five grand oh wow i put 4 800 on a
credit card and that one was my what
what the [ __ ] are you buying almost drew
me out of the house
how did you explain it what did you get
then you forgot diapers on the way home
no born i was shooting something and i
was bringing [ __ ] on the set for people
you know i was [ __ ] going on the road
and taking it with me you know this is
when lollipops were fifteen dollars a
[ __ ] piece
i'd buy ten [ __ ] lollipops to go to
houston you know
i'd walk out of there with two bags
two [ __ ] bags this is before the
podcast era this is the truth i'm not
kidding i remember my wife sitting me
down and going
yo you put 40 [ __ ] 4 thousand dollars
on a [ __ ] card
and we charges are you [ __ ] crazy
i think that's like 120 a day right
around there
i was going in there some days and
dropping 220
300 200
that was they had everything lee ice
cream cakes
they had [ __ ] everything have you
tried the pizza at uh sunset whatever no
you didn't get i didn't get it but i saw
it read pizza yeah well it's i brought
it home one night i don't know what
happened to me i fell asleep but i must
have had two thousand other edibles in
my bloodstream so
because it's apparently like i think
it's like 250 and she said it was like
you didn't even taste the
weed so i was thinking about it but
i didn't know if you had it or not
unless you're gonna sprinkle some more
wheat on that [ __ ] double check
it put some what's around that
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
let me do some shout outs and we'll get
the [ __ ] underlay on here chaz
demurrow
bob lalingus bobby sharon anthony kelly
rob bradley brian austin
or austin i don't know
paul ireland lauren rosenker and arse
warrior i love you [ __ ] tom
rhodes in the house
talking about our houston cocaine
craziness days
you were like when i started you were
like [ __ ] booming already
like when i started traveling you were
already booming and then in 95 you came
to seattle and i was doing like a gig
and i was
you did a giggle like janine garroth
along with two other people it's like a
four
comic show or something like that you
still had the long hair
and then when i first moved to l.a in 97
98
i saw you at the improv one night you
were holding on to the wall the show had
just been canceled maybe two or three
weeks prior
you were a gentleman you know and then
you took off you said [ __ ] it i'm
getting the [ __ ] outta here
you did all your travels and i bumped
into you in houston when you had the
show
and uh you had the footage of you and
the singer from [ __ ] uh
whatever the [ __ ] radar love and all
that oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i went ahead
the lightning talk show in amsterdam
yeah yeah all this [ __ ] i still remember
i mean you know you're the real [ __ ]
deal man
yeah it's great because i i left l.a
yeah thanks brother you're the real
[ __ ] no you've all uh we've always um
you know been tight and it's amazing how
you you know
you do this long enough and you see
these guys and you look at them and you
go you know i was watching you at the
store the other day
and you're a [ __ ] monster you're a
[ __ ] monster this is i look at you
and i goes yeah 20
years plus he go you just navigate
and you take him into weird places you
set yourself up you know if you were a
jiu jitsu guy you let guys get on top
yeah grab my neck
grab my neck get harder harder
what'd you just do mister i told you to
grab my neck you know if there's some
comedians who we you're the king of that
it's like you said the lights got off so
what who gives a [ __ ] we got no lights
you got ears come on let's go let's do
this show that's what a true comic does
you know like you said listen
let me tell you something if i if it's
just me and terry right now that little
girl wasn't there
i'd be out constantly i'd do this
podcast sunday and monday and i'd be on
a plane wednesday morning that's it i'd
be out there banging it out
going to places lee that
most people wouldn't go to there's a
club now whether it's toledo you go to
maine
you go some place in michigan you know
in milwaukee you go to these places and
you always know one person the week
before you get there somebody hits you
up on facebook hey man
you remember me from the store i came
back my sister got hit by a car and i
had to come back and take care of the
shoe store you know whatever
you have no idea lee
lee you have no idea the people who will
come out and see you that you look at
and you go wow
i used to [ __ ] drink with you at the
store
you were a kid what happened
because most of these people disappear
one day overnight
and your mind is so you know focused on
comedy that you your mind doesn't even
register until they hit you up on
myspace or facebook and twitter and go
hey you're coming to chicago i'm coming
to the second show
what happened to you somebody called me
in charlotte
who i've known since
1983. i robbed the sandwich store
in 1983 in an outhouse in aspen colorado
it was across the street from the hotel
and that i'm sitting there broke in this
hotel living in i'm like [ __ ] i never
robbed a sandwich store
that's the only chicken curry i ever ate
lisa
he had a chicken curry
on rye bread like multi-grain bread
these are like empty the register
make me a curry no no they were they
were gone i just kicked the door down in
those days and last but nobody had an
alarm
nobody did nothing wrong and asked me
there was no camera no burglar alarms if
you wanted something just kick the door
down i mean once a year they'd be these
burglaries and you go
there was no alarm
but there was nothing like this nobody
was dirty like me
and one day i'm just sitting in this
hotel i'm like [ __ ] i'm robbing this
sandwich guy
and i kicked the door down i probably
got him for 600
and if i got him like a few sandwiches
or something [ __ ] you know me you got to
take something to go
and the next day the owner knew
the owner knew but you know
he knew it was you but he followed the
sesame seeds no
they suspected it i just come into the
area and also they got burglarized
but steve stayed my friend and uh
his what listen to this story he was
that
at one time when i met him in 83 he was
the house center for clint jean long jet
she shot her husband or something and
she married paul williams or something
like that
some [ __ ] crazy story his girlfriend
was the house sitter in aspen everybody
has a house center you know how people
here have nannies
in the 80s in aspen you had a house in
there
i don't know what those do
what do you do to the house sitter
nothing
like when i house sat i had to do 24
hours of work a month
that's six hours of work a week so that
means either i mow the lawn or i shovel
snow
any other maintenance he had to pay
me but he left his truck there
his house was to me
and the house said it had the house in
the back
or next to over the garage you have like
one bedroom apartment and you can have a
day job
and a night job
and not pay rent and just do six hours a
week of work there
so on saturday you have to mow the lawn
trim the hedges you know clean up the
rocks you know
and on [ __ ] when it snows you have to
shovel
that's it that's all i did
but i wasn't allowed to drive the car i
drove the car
he said you were allowed to go in the
house and [ __ ] with [ __ ] i moved into
the house
you know me dog i moved into the house i
was in the jacuzzi i was i had a
weigh-in cocaine room
i had a coke room i had a room where i
put victims while they sat there and
waited for the blow
you should have seen me i was sitting
people down and calling them into the
other room
it was craziness and other than aspen in
83.
my friend jimmy berkel was the original
god bless his soul
he's [ __ ] dead his disco i love him
and i miss him
sorry about this this belt
and he [ __ ] called me
i was living in san francisco about to
get arrested
about to get arrested
okay we had to go on the run and go to
reno on one of those buses 15 a day and
they give you 15 and quarters when you
get to the hotel then so i'm in reno
and in reno i checked i had like an
answering service
and they're like you have three messages
and i call the answer service and like
yeah jimmy burke who said to call him
and i called him and he was like listen
man i knocked up my wife
and i got this house sitting job i need
for you to take it you said you were
coming up here i'm like are you [ __ ]
serious
that was like music to my ears that's
not really
that's no rent
in [ __ ] snowmass village
i get there there's a car there's a
house he's like he can't go in the house
as i'm talking to him i'm like i can't
go in the house
that house is mine
that's mine the guy only comes one week
a year he had ten of these all around
the world
this was one of his houses
in the year and a half i lived there his
daughters came out to ski one time for
three days
and left a thousand dollars worth of
booze
that were spoiled kids her father was
one of the originators of
the one food chain
he this was one of his many i used to
talk to him on the phone
from all over the world
because i had to call him before i spent
money on the house
so i would call an answering service and
he would call me back like two days
later how are you doing
i'm in finland you know what i'm saying
that sounds like a great gig
but the gig sometimes you have to live
on property with them
that sucks
it's good but it sucks
but sometimes they're not there
and they just it's a write-off for them
to have this house there jennifer
aniston has houses everywhere
and just doesn't go to them no she
[ __ ] furnishes them and puts somebody
in there to watch him so nobody
burglarizes those [ __ ] houses
and somebody lives in there you don't
even know they don't even know they're
living in jennifer anderson's houses
they don't even know they probably get
hired through a service that does a
background check and there's what they
do for a [ __ ] living
how you like them their apples [ __ ]
licker
what do you think about that dog what do
you think you're dealing with i think
that um you know why have a one house
dream you know
tgif restaurants
oh that's what the guy owes his name was
dick self
dick
dick and my buddy jimmy burke would call
me dick he's still working for dick
you ever do brad garrett's comedy club
in vegas never in the dressing room he's
got it framed it's this um
spiral notebook
that he was a waiter at tgi fridays
and when you're away my brother was a
waiter a tj fridays you know they really
make you learn the menu inside and out
they make you gotta like take a test
before you're like a bartender or a
waiter there so brad garrett has it
framed
to remind him you know how good
you he has it as being a comedian that
you know at least he's not a [ __ ]
waiter at a tgi right
yes it's like it's it's right before you
go out to go backstage to go on stage
it's like the the last thing you see i
love that that he's got his
framed
tgi friday's waiter notebook framed you
always have to have a reminder to let
you know how lucky it is i really
believe that yeah i really do i have one
every [ __ ] day like i have a reminder
of jesus [ __ ] christ
you know i was having that whole puke
episode
that i had the other day it was the main
cause of it was anxiety
don't believe diet it was anxiety i had
to leave my family i haven't done it in
six weeks
you know it's not that i got lazy i
still bang it out every night like a
[ __ ] soldier of death
you just uh it's a new adventure i
didn't know what to expect
and it turned out to be beautiful i had
a great time the city of charlotte was
[ __ ] great the club was phenomenal
the people were great the crowds were
great
the staff the food was great where do i
play the companies the comedy zone let
me tell you something they got a mexican
restaurant upstairs dog and i'm not
talking about no hip hop's magu
wrestling
i'm talking about these [ __ ]
are related to el chapo okay
these [ __ ] could cook lee cyan
everything every taco i ate i thought
about you
opening night i had two chorizo tacos
who makes chorizo tacos out of the
[ __ ] range on flour tortillas
it was delicious okay i kept it light
that's what i have for then i flew in i
didn't eat anything else
i didn't touch the rice i didn't touch
the beans okay
the next day i went back there and the
driver said you have to have the shrimp
tacos
have the carnita tacos and have the uh
chicharron tacos where's the shrimp
grilled or fried dog it was mixed in
this red sauce
with onions nothing like this these
people are schmucks these people here
get a tortilla
they put some onions they put three
shrimp caught in the bake those those
little [ __ ] base shrimps
and they get those little [ __ ] base
shrimps
and they give you some sauce
it's garbage yeah those are i don't like
those i like fried ones this was [ __ ]
sensational
i'll tell you how real they were their
chicharron tacos yeah weren't the hard
ones it was the ones mixed in sauce
they taste like a pig skin that's what
it's like it's like bald pixel when they
give you that you know they're [ __ ]
real
the best thing they had was the carnitas
i mean the pork tacos and you know i
don't eat pork
you know i don't eat pork i'm not muslim
i just don't eat pork i don't eat pork
on the road i gotta know that i got to
know where this pig came from okay
i got to know where this pig came from
i'm not muslim but i don't even pork on
them yeah i don't i don't eat pork on
the run i swear to god i've been into
that taco
it was so [ __ ] delicious i ordered
two to go that's how much of an animal i
am and i took i didn't even make it to
the hotel i ate him in the car with the
[ __ ] driver that's how stoned that
was friday night
what about the place you went to this
other place right
this asian place like this bowl place
i thought you were telling me about it
went to spaghetti place spaghetti please
that was delicious isn't that great too
like you're traveling around the country
like cities all over america and all
this surprise
i got favorite food spots i hit i was in
fort worth last weekend
uh
the flying fish it's this old place it's
been there forever
and uh they do this uh
red snapper vera cruise
i get i go every time i go to fort worth
i i go to this entire fish it's got this
tomato
onion
thick chunk sauce on top of it let me
know this is heavenly you mentioned them
so let me mention it to you
anthony bourdain when you see that show
don't you want to put a gun in your head
and shoot yourself that was you
that's what you did for the last 20
years yeah well i still want to do that
i want to make that show but with
comments
i got comedian friends all over the
world and comedies hot all over the
world i can still make that show i made
a lot of short videos i have them on
youtube uh i made a uh like travel clips
and and trying to make a comedy chat
this is a web series that you could do
but i i i guarantee you the first season
you will get picked up by somebody
if you do this i'm still trying to make
that show 11-minute snippets and put out
one a week on your [ __ ] travels
i got some on youtube i got malaysia i
got ireland i got uh hanoi vietnam i got
cambodia um
i've made some noise after the marriage
you had to have some footage before the
marriage and [ __ ] of the real-time
waking up on the floor with no shirt on
and bisbee [ __ ] whatever the stan
hope compound the next day you're in
vegas right because that's what
this whole thing we were talking about
in the beginning that people really
don't know when you're out there lee
you're out there
some days you wake up on a beautiful
[ __ ] bed
with a curtain and the room smells like
louis the lilac
i don't know buddy i think he had very
comfortable bedding
and some days you wake up on a couch
that was the part about the road that
most gentiles
most people never understand
when you're explaining to somebody about
your life and they're like so tell us
about what you do you're like thursday
night i was in charleston south carolina
really was the hotel nice hotel lady
that club has the what was the club in
cleveland that had the
the [ __ ] sleeping in the back of it
no that was in akron uh kyogre falls
tell lisa
that the [ __ ] beer guy would come
you'd be sleeping in a cop
and the big guy would have to push you
they locked you in another
you stayed they had like an old
warehouse storage space
it had been converted to apartments for
the comedians
what did you do as you walk in with your
suitcase all excited i do for i was
never going to perform there because i
can't do coke in the dark i would lose
too much of it well i got a story for
you oh yeah i got lost
i got a
i was there in february and it was big
snow drifts and massive snow storms so
me and the other comedian were snowed in
for the week so it was like being in
jail
it was like being in jail the the they
had a a a metal door in the back of the
club
they would unlock it when they when the
owner and the waitresses got to the club
you could hear him unlock that metal
door and it felt like being in jail it's
like oh now we can go into the club like
at seven or whatever so there was no
windows
it's really dark in there but this is
jesus i don't remember what what what
year this was but
it was just i was the feature act the
the headliner was this guy from
uh
indianapolis
and
he was like a portly bald
pervert guy
remember the usa network this is like i
think the early 90s maybe maybe 89
something like that the usa network on
cable in the afternoon they had this
teen dance party usa show i don't know
if you remember that no so it's like
somewhere like texas or mexico all these
like little teenage kids
in
bathing suits and bikinis it was a dance
show for like an hour
and like you know so this guy's
it was like little teenage kids
dancing on you know at a beach with with
bathing suits on so you know it was a
show for for kids for like no one ever
invited me to that so there's this this
portly pervert guy that i'm working with
he's watching it every day and they're
like they would do like a marathon of
them like three or four episodes back to
back so all afternoon this guy is just
sitting here watching these things and
you know we might have been smoking a
little pot or who knows what i mean i'm
probably
20 years old
uh
and he turns to me one day and he says
want to watch me want to watch videos of
me [ __ ] my wife
what and i say
who wouldn't
so he gets his video camera he gets his
video camera
he puts the wires onto the back of the
tv
and he puts on this
this this video and it's he's like this
fat bald guy and his wife was like
portly and unattractive it was the last
two people in the world you would ever
want to see with their clothes off and i
think i lasted about two minutes
three minutes and then i just went um
you know i'm gonna go read
i went into my little room and then i
still had to stay with this guy for like
three days
he showed it was like it was really
uncomfortable and i was like man he
knows what else uh
i worked with a guy one time
this had to be 98.99
this guy was infatuated with jennifer
lopez
jennifer lopez had just released that
album
and he would play it in his room over
and over
and over and over and he would dance and
he had pictures of it this was a grown
man guys
this was not a 21 year old
all right so
i had to be maybe 38. he was maybe 42.
he had lived in la for 10 years didn't
do so well and moved back to his
hometown
and for four days i had to work el paso
with him he didn't do drugs
so i had to go in my bedroom and bring
broads in there late night and [ __ ] and
all he did was listen to jennifer lopez
he was a grown man with a wife and kids
wow
and it was something you couldn't even
talk to him
right away jennifer lopez is hot man
you have any idea how i can meet
jennifer lopez i mean it was that
[ __ ] creepy like
i've never seen him again and that's
what you work with in those other clubs
you work with lunatics
you work with guys that came out here
and something happened there's a story
and now they're mad at la people who
live in that last dick if you live in
new york you suck dick you know it's
just
and it's a nightmare each of them have a
[ __ ] thing
so you gotta deal with it the best ever
was el paso
some of my best stories
had to be el paso that i've forgotten
like the angel salazar weeks and it was
just craziness lisa remember you could
go over to juarez was great yes man i
had some good great party nights in
juarez one time i got scared i never
went really yeah one time
the first time i went i went over there
they're selling leathers and dogs on the
street and [ __ ] and none of that i had i
had some good oh you could buy my pills
and [ __ ] and bring them over no no no i
came back like
three four in the morning in the jail
the the border control guy
i said uh
i go it wasn't as dangerous as everybody
says or you hear about and the border
patrol guy goes you got lucky
i guess i don't know maybe i did get
lucky
no that uh
i was scared enough in el paso
but one time i worked out pastor with a
hypnotist
and this is my best [ __ ] comedy story
out of all those years that i remember i
still remember waking up
new year's day the millennium two to yk
yeah he was
two was that it two why two two thousand
yeah two thousand and i worked with him
but
he was a drunk
people didn't go out that night on new
year's eve remember they were afraid i
was in san francisco we had 60 people
yeah he would the the bart was pissed
if he was if everyone was afraid the
world was gonna explode because the
number was gonna roll to three zeros oh
my god this guy comes in
and he uh
you know he's drinking uh
like a special scotch the one that comes
in a bag
but that's part of his deal crab royal
no yeah maybe it's in a caramel one
comes in a
yeah it comes in a bag
and uh
and there was something else he's
drinking
and he's just driving crazy he's smoking
he's snorting blow
you know this guy's on [ __ ] fire
right okay
so i wake up uh
new year's day
i'm a little i know i don't get high on
new year's i i usually don't get high on
new year's which is bad luck
so i get up new year's eve
and i see that he's already got he's
doing a kids show
all right but the kids show starts at
noon it's 8 30. he's already got a half
gallon of wine next
already got you got blue apron over
there tarzan
you're sitting there like a [ __ ]
bumpy you see i'm over here confused
uh
that's it what's this
you got one page for uncle joey he's
sitting there
at [ __ ] 8 30 guys with a tuxedo shirt
on with suspenders no pants on boxer
shorts some black party socks
and [ __ ] shoes on with no [ __ ]
pants just sitting there smoking a joint
chasing it with a cigarette he's got a
little get ready for the kids get ready
for the kids dog
he [ __ ] decides to go in there and
just
eats
the i don't know what's wrong no don't
worry about it he just eats a bag of
dicks but he's getting bart mad because
before the show he's drinking those
[ __ ] shots he's already bombed
he's already bumped up on 11 30. yeah
when he tells me he's walking through
the thing i go you know what i'm gonna
walk down there with you because i gotta
see this it don't take a genius to know
this is gonna be a train wreck
i walked him down there skipping down
the [ __ ] hill like nothing happened
we go in there there's kids everywhere
he goes right to the bar yeah i'm like
give him a shot you know you know me you
might as well buy him a shot bart sees
this magician whatever the [ __ ] he is
it's his drinking
he's going nuts he's pacing back and
forth
he does two or three shots before he
goes on stage he goes on stage sure
enough
he brings the kid up and the kid looks
at the midway and he goes you stink
the kid tells him he's stuck he stomped
like booze man
and he don't know what to do the pigeons
disappear
one
i'm in the background
listen you have to
if you didn't know this is going to be a
[ __ ] train wreck but he's the best
now he's frustrated he's at the bar the
turnout wasn't good because he got like
a door deal
nobody's happy the kids are crying
bart's crying guys crying the kids are
crying
oh my god i'm [ __ ] howling at the bar
now to make things worse what do you
think this [ __ ] magician hit slashing
that's his thoughts he calls their mom's
guns he gets
how can this get any worse
he pulls his dick out he wants a double
what happens he orders a double meal
he lights another cigarette
on stage in front of the kids no at the
bar there's stuff kids they're crying
kids want their money back and [ __ ] he
goes let me get a double and he sparks
up a cigarette and he's at the bar he's
jiggling the ice cream
i know this is gonna get it and listen
when the kid came up to him and asked
him for an autograph or something i
forget what it was
i saw bart's face
get [ __ ] red because he just
he took the cigarette and put it in his
mouth and took the picture
italy
that's the beauty of the road
that you get to see [ __ ] like that and
that's like something that you'll think
about your last 10 minutes on this earth
like that vision should come to you
without going doing that like i we've
i've never laughed that hard seeing that
evolve in front of me there was ten more
that i probably forgot so many scenes in
your life as a comedian you think if if
you saw this in a movie you'd think
that's there's no way that would happen
you know
i was towing a car
from seattle
to san francisco
i have questions already bro let's go
i'm towing a car
from seattle to los angeles but the deal
is we're driving the trailer and the car
is in a hitch behind us
okay
the girl i'm with i say drop me off on
an open mic in san francisco
and come back and pick me up in 15 20
minutes
i do the set i come out i call her
as she's going around the turn i see the
back of the [ __ ]
the back of the trailer just fall
and she's still driving
but the car goes poof and the trailer
broke the whole [ __ ] thing
so we had to get it welded so we had to
take it to some shady neighborhood
overnight and we had to sleep in the
trailer with the car in the back
i listen guys at three in the morning an
open mic started right outside the
trailer
as pissed as i was i was [ __ ] howling
she even woke up and said what the [ __ ]
you laughing about you should be out
there saying something i go listen to
what they're doing they were playing a
guitar
they were smoking dope and i remember
howling to myself
nobody would ever believe this
that these people wouldn't play this
guitar anywhere else right now but
outside this [ __ ] trailer right now
this is the [ __ ] that i don't know
do you travel the
who the [ __ ] knows
no i'd like to eventually but not not
right now if we [ __ ] get the big time
then when you go on the road every
weekend we'll get you drugs oh no no not
like that yeah no what are you gonna
have to do sleep in hotel rooms get room
service what are you ten
if you go out it's to go deep into the
hemisphere yeah four nights a week
drinking passing out bleeding out of the
[ __ ]
anyway let's give a shout out to the
sponsors get the [ __ ] out of here tommy
road it's late
people got [ __ ] these little people i
love you so much joey no i'm happy you
can do it i'm very happy man
okay so you can admit the last thing
anybody wants to do after work is wait
in line at a grocery store schlep home
and cook a complicated meal it's
expensive unhealthy takeout is hardly
any better that's where a new service
comes in blue apron jack blue apron
delivers farm fresh ingredients
step-by-step recipes to your home
allowing you to create healthy
hand-crafted meals at home without going
to the grocery store for less than ten
dollars per meal listen to me for less
than ten dollars a meal blue apron sends
you fresh ingredients perfectly
proportioned making cooking healthy
meals real easy and fun no trips to the
grocery store no waste from unused
ingredients plus you'll learn how to
cook with specialty ingredients that are
normally hard to find blue apron is also
perfect for date night cooking with
friends and they even offer a family
plan with kid-friendly ingredients so
the whole family can eat well and have
fun preparing the meals together each
balanced meal is 500 to 700 calories per
serving and they taste so good you don't
even know you have no idea and to boot
shipping is flexible and free and the
menus are always new they won't send the
same meal twice they work around your
schedule and dietary preferences and
blue apron experts source only the best
seasonal ingredients listen they've sent
them to my house let me tell you what
they got this week steak tacos okay with
salsa verde they got spicy orange
chicken wings
for the family plant they got hoisin
glazed pork and spinach ricotta calzones
and manhattan style fish chocolate
that's the kind of who knows how to make
fish chowder nobody but you learn now
that you're doing one time with this
you'll cook incredible meals and be
blown away by the quality and the
freshness blue apron is the better way
to cook trust me you work too hard to be
messing with this to get the meals
delivered right to your door no must no
fuss everything is prepared for you you
just read the directions bang it out and
by 6 30 you're in front of the couch
eating like a soldier plain and simple
it's healthy so that's it blue apron
it's a better way to cook check out this
week's menu and get your two first meals
for free
grab us by going to blueapron.com
joey that's blowingpin.com
joey my treat really the first two meals
are on me when you go to blue dot com
slash joey how's that for you uh ricardo
month and mine sounds fantastic i'm
happy that you're not drinking no more
that was good thanks brother
not to like give a [ __ ] if you were
drinking but sometimes and it's funny
you couldn't have done this 20 years ago
it's your wisdom you know where you're
going every warrior needs to move on to
wise man you see i'm saying lisa you're
taking notes kind of [ __ ] just
sitting there like zombo with your eyes
all red
anyway valentine's day is coming
so i'll tell you what one of the best
things you could give somebody
is me undies and i'll tell you why
because i wear me on these all the time
especially when i do different sporting
events if your boyfriend goes to jiu
jitsu or he wants to lift weights he
always wants to be comfortable
there's nothing that a man wants to do
is lift weights over his head and his
nuts fall out of his shorts nobody wants
to be that [ __ ] guy even if nobody
sees him you know it and it's [ __ ]
uncomfortable it [ __ ] with your head
this is why me on this is for you
me undies is for you i'm sorry for you
what the [ __ ] am i talking about don't
be predictable and show up on your
valentine's dinner with some last minute
box of chocolates or bouquet of roses
that are gonna die in a week anyway
give the gift everybody's talking about
show your special someone just how much
you care with a present you both love a
gift that looks great and feels great
and in some ways says you deserve the
best treat yourself and your boo to a
matching pair of my undies the world's
most comfortable underwear let me
explain something to you for you
[ __ ] that ain't romantic on
[ __ ] drop it on them you show
up at your girlfriend's house with
underwear for you and her that match
that's a tremendous ball lick that
that's as
they pick up your helmet and lick that
thing like it's the last fountain the
[ __ ]
the last fountain out there in the dead
with wreaths with the spoon she was
stuck on the mountain out there she was
sucking that pipe that's what they do
anyway
this underwear is as comfy as it gets me
on these are made with micro more doll
fabric
meaning they're twice as soft as cotton
you understand me micro more dog fabric
and they just don't feel great they look
great too they may even make me look
handsome you got to see my lower body
when i got my undies on i look like
[ __ ] mercado mountain bum beyond
these comes in tons of cool prints and
styles and new designs come out every
week you won't want to miss february's
limited edition design from legendary
artist keith herring you know what that
is tremendous this retreat
this metro design is inspired by love
making it the perfect valentine's day
gift grab yourself a pair right now
celebrate the holiday sporting matching
underwear with your sweetheart and my
undies has a keeper for free guarantee
if you don't fall in love with your
first pair you keep them you get your
money back no questions asked and what
i'm gonna do is this this year
valentine's day head to meyondis.com
joey now and get free shipping and 25
off your first order don't wait there
until the last minute like a mooch get a
matching pair this month limited edition
print while you still can and get 20
percent off
dot com slash joey 20 off at
myunders.com joey order before february
4th
that's thursday in the u.s to make sure
your pay arrives in time for valentine's
day with no mistakes no
misunderstandings that's meundies.com
joey for free shipping and 20 off your
first order
so you can get it and you'll get up with
the world's most comfortable underwear
and as usual on it.com you know what i'm
saying that's why i'm looking so [ __ ]
handsome these days
i flew with [ __ ] creepy looking
people even though there's 23 of them
and i made it i ain't coughing i ain't
sneezing you know why shroom tech
[ __ ] not the sport but the
immune bam look at lisa
dropping [ __ ] hot tonight also the
hemp force protein i can't tell you how
much i love that cocoa with a banana
some water bam but who the [ __ ] am i to
tell you what to drink they have a
selection of [ __ ] that'll blow your mind
from little potions with water energy
drinks the testosterone booster but do
me a favor don't take it from me go to
honor.com right now get the party
started make the move go to honor.com
right now you see something you like go
to the box and press in church boom get
ten percent off your first order
delivered right to your house like a
[ __ ] soldier all right i want to
thank me undies i want to thank annette
and i want to thank blue apron the best
foods delivered to your house fresh
[ __ ]
who's that you know who it is anyway
where you at where you at in the next
couple of weeks uh i'm in california i'm
in sacramento next week at the punch
line at the punch line and then uh
i think it's the 15th or something i'm
doing arcata have you ever done arcata
up in humboldt county it's where
humboldt state is okay fantastic place
up there uh then i'm doing uh it's
called jambalaya okay i think it's the
15th
then i'm doing mill valley the throck
morton on the tuesday this is just next
week and then uh the san francisco
punchline um after that you're [ __ ]
beautiful i'm i'm california for
february really yeah and then what are
you going to march
tacoma washington the tacoma comedy club
you ever done that that place is
supposed to be fantastic
in seattle yeah
and then i'm doing scottsdale arizona in
march also
you're a [ __ ] animal dog it's a
it's a blessing what we do
it's a blessing you're still out there
you know you look good you're healthy
you're married
sometimes
to think about life sometimes
what you thought turns into something
else and that's what makes it life
if it was as easy as you thought it was
going to be like some guy i'm going to
marry a nurse and
grow up and have 10 kids the next thing
you know you married some [ __ ]
chinese chick you end up in [ __ ]
southeast asia taking pictures of young
kids before i was a headshot you know
i'm saying [ __ ] up no but it's like
you know you know i watch you and it's
just you know you just you just keep
getting better it's just like it's what
we do you're you're a wrecking ball now
you know it's beautiful to see like uh
you know i just turned 49 last week you
know you're a couple just a couple years
older than me just to like be hitting
our peak
in our 50s if you would again lee and i
say this that i would be out there
working when i was 53 on the road i tell
you you were crazy i mean like i've
never been i've never been better you
know i'm i'm really i'm really excited
i'm uh working
on my new hour so for my next special
you know um
it's just it's just fun and exciting
again i love it i mean it's always been
fun and exciting but like uh i feel like
it's never been better you know and i
watch you and it's like yeah man like
carlin you know that at the end
that was his best work that he ever did
in his life his like last five specials
right now there's so many great and i
know you guys are sick of hearing it but
there's so many great comedians working
that aren't in the rotation which means
they aren't it comedians
you know they moved back to new york
whatever happened
and these are the guys that lee would go
catch and go who the [ __ ] is that guy
yeah and he would have like a tonight
show credit or some suspicious credit
but it didn't matter the guy was a great
comic
he just didn't go down the right road or
or go to the right club or just
something must have happened there's a
thousand of those guys across the
country that have a day job that said
you know what that [ __ ] wasn't for me
i'm blue collar i want to work every day
i don't want people to tell me what the
[ __ ] they do and
you know
and they're still great comedians you
can't take it away from them we go watch
the people who are hip and who's in the
circle you know all that [ __ ] because
that's what we do you know i would do
the same thing when i go to a list and i
see a comic that's got heat i sit and
watch them what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] that's what it's all about
you got to be aware of what's going on
what's going on so
now i enjoy it when i was out there
pimping doing drugs i never went to
comedy shows did you know that when i
was out there slinging a dick i never
thought about sitting there for two
hours [ __ ] you i got a package in my
pocket i ain't sitting nowhere for two
hours unless you're naked beat me down
with a pogo stick [ __ ]
let's wrap this [ __ ] up i'm
gonna be at this helium in st louis
thursday through saturday and then on
the 19th and the 20th
at the south point comedy for my
birthday on the 19th i'll be 53 lisa
yeah it's coming my man larry is coming
talking leia's coming
esther coo is coming on the drums and
that's it that's all i got to tell you
[ __ ] as usual
always a [ __ ] pleasure seeing you uh
jesus [ __ ] christ
unbelievable i used to watch you on mtv
when i first started and go wow look at
him he [ __ ] with the long hair
looking all [ __ ] cool
and that's it lisa yeah what's happening
in your world cocksmoker i'm doing great
i'm doing life in neutral it's a new
podcast it's been i've like got four
episodes and you want to try it you're
doing great yeah me and johnny rock it's
going great you're looking good you
going to kettlebells tomorrow if i can
yeah yeah all right i'll call you
tomorrow morning we'll figure this out
if [ __ ] yeah you're looking beautiful
[ __ ] thanks for
co-hosting this [ __ ] tonight it was fun
yeah put a little music on at the end
uh sure but kind of yeah
put a little music for us maybe a little
[ __ ] wheels of confusion by black
sabbath or something like that
set them off in the right state of mind
at least
i just heard that one last night i'm
like this is a [ __ ] groovy goddamn
song
we'll continue this on my podcast yeah
absolutely do you wanna switch to
periscope so because so i can turn off
youtube
if you want to for the song
jesus christ i don't worry about it
let's just go okay i'll see you guys
tomorrow guys thank you stay black